ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY TODAY'S
TUESDAY MARCH TWELFTH.
AND WE DO NOT YET HAD TO HAVE A
QUORUM BUT WE HAVE SUFFICIENT
MEMBERS TO START AS A SUB
COMMITTEE SO WE WILL DO JUST
THAT.
AND OUR FIRST BILL IS GOING TO
BE MR GABRIEL SO WE'LL START
WITH ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
.
FOR TWENTY FOUR HI GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TODAY TO
PRESENT A. B..
FOUR TWO FOUR WHICH CLARIFIES
EXISTING LAW REGARDING THE
ADMISSIBILITY OF CERTAIN
DEPOSITION TRANSCRIPTS.
AS YOU MAY BE AWARE CALIFORNIA
IS CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING A
SHORTAGE OF LICENSE COURT
REPORTERS.
THIS SORTED SHORTAGE HAS CAUSED
MANY ATTORNEYS TO RELY ON
UNLICENSED VIDEOGRAPHERS TO
RECORD THEIR DEPOSITIONS WITH
THE TRANSCRIPT TO BE PREPARED AT
A LATER DATE.
VIDEOTAPED DEPOSITIONS ARE
ADMISSIBLE IN COURT UNDER
CERTAIN CONDITIONS BUT CONFUSION
EXISTS ABOUT WHO MAY LAWFULLY
TRANSCRIBE RECORDED DEPOSITIONS
AND WHAT IS REQUIRED TO ENSURE
THAT TRANSCRIPTS OF THOSE
DEPOSITIONS.
CAN BE ADMITTED WITHOUT
CONTROVERSY AB FOR TWO FOUR
RESOLVES THIS CONFUSION BY
AMENDING THE CODE OF CIVIL
PROCEDURE. TO CLARIFY THAT ONLY
A CALIFORNIA LICENSED COURT
REPORTER MAY STENOGRAPHY
TRANSCRIBE RECORDED DEPOSITION.
THIS BILL PROTECTS THE PUBLIC IN
THAT AGAINST BY ENSURING THE
TRANSCRIPTS FROM VIDEOTAPED
DEPOSITIONS ARE PREPARED BY
LICENSE REPORTERS WHO ARE
COMPETENT QUALIFIED AND
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE COURT
REPORTERS BOARD.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE AND WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS JAMES
GROSS ON BEHALF OF THE
DEPOSITION REPORTERS ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU FIRST WHEN THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR --
MR GABRIEL SUMMARIZED IT VERY
WELL -- THIS
IS A IMPORTANT CLARIFICATION IT
IS TECHNICAL BUT NONE THE LESS --
WILL ELIMINATE CONFUSION WITH --
BOTH THE VIDEO ARE GRAFFITI
ITSELF AND WHO IS APPROPRIATE
AND LEGALLY REQUIRED TO
TRANSCRIBE IT WE ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
TWENTY GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS ARE NOT YOUR
HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COURT REPORTERS
ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE KIND OF AN IN BETWEEN
OPPOSITION RIGHT NOW AND I THINK
ON THE SOMEONE NUMBER SO STAFF
SPOKE YESTERDAY ALSO THE
SPONSORS WILL START
CONVERSATIONS.
WOULD YOU SUPPORT THE CONCEPT.
OF THIS BILL WE DO BELIEVE THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
CLARIFICATION SOME WORK DONE IN
THIS AREA --
TO PROTECT THE INTEGRITY OF THE
TRANSCRIPT AND VIDEO --
ONLY A DEPOSITION PROCEEDINGS --
WE DO HAVE SOME IDEAS ON ON
MAYBE SOME --
STRONGER OR EVEN MORE EFFECTIVE
WAYS TO DO THAT --
SO WE'LL CONTINUE OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
THE SPONSOR HOPEFULLY WE GET TO
A POINT TO BE OFFICIALLY SUPPORT
WE DO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT --
OR ASSOCIATION HAS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT TAKE ON THE DRIVERS OF
A PERCEIVED --
VARIOUS COUNTIES FOR OFFICIAL
COURT REPORTER POSITIONS FOR
EXAMPLE WE ALSO SEEN.
OF A VAST ARRAY OF A REPORTERS
AVAILABLE FOR DEPOSITIONS BUT
THERE ARE SOME STRUCTURAL --
ISSUES SO WE WE DON'T BELIEVE
THAT THERE IS IS A LARGE OF A
PERCEIVED.
AS AS SOME FOLKS MAY SAY --
BUT WE DO THINK THAT THERE NEEDS
TO BE WORKING ON THIS VIDEO
DEPOSITION ARENA SO WE DO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORED SPONSOR TO GETTING TO
SUPPORT POSITION AND I THANK
THEM FOR BRINGING THE BILL.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
OR IN BETWEEN.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
MORNING GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS KATHY DE LORENZO I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF COURT REPORTING WITH
PLANET DUBOSE.
A COURT REPORTING FIRM WITH
BUSINESS INTERESTS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA --
I HAVE BEEN.
STENNETT GRAPHICALLY TRAINED AND
CREDENTIALED AS A COURT REPORTER
AND HAVE BEEN IN THE BUSINESS
FOR NEARLY FORTY YEARS.
THE SHORTAGE.
IN THE COURT REPORTING
PROFESSION ISRAEL I HAVE COPIES
OF THE REPORT HERE THAT WAS
COMMISSIONED BY THE NATIONAL
COURT REPORTERS ASSOCIATION BACK
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN I DO HAVE
COPIES AVAILABLE.
THE SHORTAGE IS ACKNOWLEDGED AS
THE SPONSOR SAID BY.
AGENCIES ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES WHO ARE EAGER TO COVER
THEIR CALENDARS ALSO THE THE D.
R. A. THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL
STATE ASSOCIATIONS AS WELL AS
THE NATIONAL COURT REPORTERS
ASSOCIATION.
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN THE REPORT
CONCLUDED THAT THERE WOULD BE
FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED OPEN
POSITIONS.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND HE DID
RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA SINCE
THAT TIME THREE HUNDRED SIXTEEN
HAVE BEEN CERTIFIED WHICH IS.
MORE THAN TWO THOUSAND SHY OF
THE REQUIRED.
NUMBER AT THAT THE REPORT
PREDICTED.
THAT'S NOT TO INCLUDE THOSE ARE
WHO ARE RETIRING EACH AND EVERY
DAY AT THE TIME THE REPORT WAS
COMMISSIONED THERE WERE SIXTEEN
COURT REPORTING PROGRAMS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SINCE THEN SEVEN OF
THEM HAVE CLOSED AND NINE REMAIN.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THERE'S OF
THAT THE SCHOOL CLOSURES IS A
REDUCTION IN THE NUMBER OF
ENROLLEES A REDUCTION IN THE
NUMBER WHO ARE GRADUATING AND OF
COURSE THEN THERE A REDUCTION IN
THE NUMBER WHO ARE TESTING IT
BECOMING CERTIFIED?
COURT REPORTERS IN CALIFORNIA.
AS OF RIGHT NOW WE FIND NO
VIABLE SOLUTION TO REVERSE THE
TREND IN STENOGRAPHIC REPORTING
TO RECOVER FROM THE LOSSES THAT
WE'VE HAD IN THE PAST --
THE CALIFORNIA SHORT HIM
REPORTERS BOARD HAS SUGGESTED --
AND JUST RECENTLY --
APPROVED VOICE TECHNOLOGY
REPORTERS WHO CONTEST FOR THE
CSR EXAM BUT AT THE MOMENT OF
THOSE NINE SCHOOLS THAT ARE IN
PLACE IN CALIFORNIA NONE OF THEM
ARE.
SET UP AND IMPLEMENTING VOICE
TECHNOLOGY AND A PHONE CALL LAST
WEEK.
WITH THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF
THE CALIFORNIA SHORTHAND
REPORTER SUPPORTIVE ON FENNER
SHE SAID THAT THEY WILL SOON BE
LOOKING OUT THE REQUIREMENTS THE
CURRICULUM REQUIREMENTS FOR
VOICE TECHNOLOGY AND THAT IS NOT
EXPECTED --
TO TAKE PLACE FOR ANOTHER
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR MONTHS
THAT'S HOW LONG THE PROCESS IS
EXPECTED TO LAST --
ANOTHER TECHNOLOGY THAT IS --
SAID TO BE AT AN OPTION ON THE
TABLE IS REMOTE TECHNOLOGY WHICH
BASICALLY MEANS THAT A A
REPORTER HERE IN SACRAMENTO
COULD COVER A DEPOSITION DOWN IN
LOS ANGELES.
REMOTELY AND PROVIDED THAT
ACCEPTABLE AND IT'S OKAY FOR THE
COURT REPORTER NOT TO BE IN THE
ROOM WE'RE STILL DEALING WITH A
FINITE NUMBER OF COURT REPORTERS.
WHO ARE ABLE TO COVER THOSE
PROCEEDINGS?
DIGITAL REPORTING ANOTHER --
OPTION AS WELL AS VIDEO
REPORTING THAT IS INCLUDED IN
THIS BILL IS BEING USED NOW TO
SUPPLEMENT STENOGRAPHIC COURT
REPORTERS THESE DIGITAL
REPORTERS ARE TRAINED IN THE
EXACT SAME.
PROCEDURES PROTOCOL CODE OF
ETHICS THAT STENOGRAPHIC
REPORTERS ART ARE TRAINED AND
THE BOTTOM LINE THE TRANSCRIPT
IS WHAT WILL ALWAYS BE A
VERBATIM.
EXCUSE ME AN ACCURATE VERBATIM
RECORD OF RECORD OF THE
PROCEEDINGS.
MA'AM I DO NEED WRAP UP THE SURE
ALL WRAPPED UP IN SORRY OKAY --
AS OF RIGHT NOW TRANSCRIPTION IN.
AN IN DEPOSITIONS THAT ARE TAKEN
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA IN STATE
THEN YOU'D CASES ARE BEING DONE
BY COURT REPORTERS ALL OVER THE
UNITED STATES THERE ARE NOT
CALIFORNIA CS OURS.
THERE IS NO ISSUE WITH
ADMISSIBILITY IN COURT LIKEWISE
THE FEDERAL THE THE FEDERAL
COURTS ARE USING TRANSCRIPTION
IS ALL ACROSS THE NATION TO
TRANSCRIBE DIGITALLY RECORDED
PROCEEDINGS.
AND FOR ALL OF THESE REASONS WE
OPPOSE A BEFORE TWENTY FOUR I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN A
POSITION PLEASE.
GET COME THE MICROPHONE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN MY NAME IS
SUSAN IMPERIAL I'M A
CALIFORNIA'S CSR OF OVER TWENTY
TWO YEARS.
I AM ALSO THERE CURRENTLY THE
DIRECTOR OF DIGITAL REPORTING
FOR STORY CLOUD.
THIS BILL FARMS THREE
CONSTITUENCIES THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA NEEDING LEGAL
SERVICES PARTICULARLY LOW INCOME
WILL SUFFER ADVERSELY IF THIS
BILL PASSES.
DIGITAL REPORTING SLASH
RECORDING ALLOWS FOR A
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN COSTS
DUE TO SCALABILITY.
THE ECONOMICS OF THE PROPOSED
STENOGRAPHIC REQUIREMENT OF
TRANSCRIPTION MAKES COST
EFFICIENCY IMPOSSIBLE THAT'S
PUTTING OUT OF REACH.
FAIR AND APPROPRIATE LEGAL
REPRESENTATION FOR THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIA LEGAL CONSUMERS.
ATTORNEYS FACING OWNERS COSTS OF
STENOGRAPHIC TRANSCRIPTIONS
SERVICES CANNOT REPRESENT THEIR
CLIENTS ADEQUATELY OR OPTIMALLY.
CONVERSELY DIGITAL REPORTING
SLASH RECORDING DUE TO COST
EFFICIENCY.
ALLOWS THE ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA TO BE MORE EFFECTIVE
ADVOCATES ON BEHALF OF THEIR
CLIENTS.
COURT REPORTERS THEMSELVES ARE
ALSO ADVERSELY AFFECTED.
BY LIMITING REPORTERS TO THE
TASK.
OF EDITING TRANSCRIPTION WHICH
MANY IF NOT MOST COURT REPORTERS
CURRENTLY DO NOT OPT TO DO.
THEY HAVE A HIGHER SCOPE IS TO
DO THAT.
YOU ARE NOT ONLY RELEGATING THEM
TO THE TASK OF EDITING.
BUT YOU HE TO WORK EFFECTIVELY
AS REPORTERS.
MOREOVER THERE IS AN
OVERWHELMING SHORTAGE AS HAS
BEEN MENTIONED OF STENOGRAPHIC
REPORTERS CURRENTLY IN
CALIFORNIA.
AS WELL AS NATIONWIDE DUE TO
UNTENABLE COMPETENCY THRESHOLDS.
AND THE CLOSING OF COURT
REPORTING SCHOOLS UP AND DOWN
THE STATE.
IN ADDITION YOU ARE DENYING
QUALIFIED EDITORS AND SCOPE IS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO WHAT THEY
DO BEST PREPARE QUALITY
TRANSCRIPTS.
YOU WOULD BE PUTTING OUT OF
BUSINESS THOUSANDS OF QUALIFIED
CALIFORNIA'S SCOPUS WHAT
WORSENING THE ALREADY ADVERSE
STATUS OF THE CURRENT
STENOGRAPHIC COURT REPORTING
LABOR MARKET.
BOTTOM LINE THIS BILL WILL
GREATLY DIMINISH THE NUMBER OF
TRANSCRIPTION JOBS IN CALIFORNIA
WITHOUT PROVIDING [inaudible]
ADEQUATE.
WOMAN AND MAN POWER. TO DO THE
JOB OF EDITING TRANSCRIPTION.
AND IT WILL ADVERSELY HARM THE
CITIZENS ATTORNEYS REPORTERS AND
SCOPAS OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL THROWS THE CALIFORNIA
COURT REPORTING INDUSTRY INTO
CHAOS.
AND IT DOES NOT COOL THE FIRE IT
FUELS THE FIRE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SEE NONE OF BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMON.
ALL RIGHTS --
SEEING NONE OF US TO GABRIEL I A
THANK YOU I KNOW WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE AND TRYING
TO ESTABLISH THE LEVEL QUALITY
FOR COURT REPORTERS AND
STENOGRAPHERS WHICH I THINK IS
CRITICAL.
FROM MY STANDPOINT YOUR BILL
ABSOLUTELY PASSES MUSTER FOR
THIS COMMITTEE I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
AND SHOULD LIKE YOU CAN CLOSE I
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH AND
ALL YOUR WORK MISTER CHAIRMAN
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ONCE WE GET A QUORUM
WE WILL DO THAT IN A SECOND.
WE DON'T YET HAVE A CORE WHEN WE
DO WE WILL.
CALL FOR A VOTE WONDERFUL LA
TAKE VERY MUCH [inaudible]
MR GIPSON.
THIS TAKES US TO ITEM NUMBER TWO
AB
.
ONE SEVENTY FIVE GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
SEVENTY FIVE WITH SIX TO
MODERNIZE THE FOSTER YOUTH BILL
OF RIGHTS BY ADDING RIGHTS.
THAT ARE INCLUSIVE OF THE YOUTH
EXPERIENCING EASILY ACCESSIBLE --
TO EMPOWER THEIR DECISION MAKING
THE FOSTER YOU HAVE THE OLD HAVE
TO OVERCOME INSURMOUNTABLE ODDS
AND HAVE A HIGH RATE OF
UNEMPLOYMENT.
AND INCARCERATION THESE YOU TURN
TO THAT CAN HELP THEM UNDERSTAND
THE RESOURCES AND THE RIGHTS
ENTITLED TO THEM UNDER THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
HELLO BACKGROUND IN TWO THOUSAND
AND ONE SENATOR --
SENATE BILL EIGHT NINE NINE BY
LOU ECSTATIC TO FALL FOR YOU THE
BILL OF RIGHTS.
AND REQUIRED THE SOCIAL WORKER
TO NOTIFY FOSTER YOU --
UP THERE IN A LITTLE RIGHTS IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN I AUTHORS
SIMPLY BUILT TEN SIXTY SEVEN
WHICH WAS FIVE BY THE END
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO
CONVENE A WORK GROUP. TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS AN UPDATE
PROVISIONS TO THE FOSTER YOUTH
BILL OF RIGHTS.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SEVENTY FIVE
IS BEFORE YOU TODAY AT
SPECIFICALLY THE RIGHTS TO
RECEIVE GROOMING.
HI GENE PRODUCTS.
REGARDLESS OF SEXUAL ORIENTATION
AND GENDER IDENTIFICATION. TO BE
REFERRED TO REFERRED --
TO BY THEIR PREFERRED NAME OR
PRONOUN.
DO YOU HAVE REASONABLE ACCESS TO
COMPUTER TECHNOLOGY.
AND THE INTERNET AMONG OTHERS.
WITH ME TO HEAR TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY --
FOR ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SEVENTY
FIVE IS REVEREND LINDA DO HER
SOON THAT'S THEIR RIGHT PRETTY
GOOD OKAY --
OF THE TABLE.
AT THIS CHURCH A FOSTER PARENT
AND THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM
CALIFORNIA YOU CONNECTION IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
ONE SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU FIRST
WITH US PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND YET YOU SPEAK IN
THE MICROPHONE THAT THAT BECOME
NERVOUS.
I CAN GET A BREEZE.
GREAT.
OKAY THERE YOU GO --
MY NAME IS LINDA DO HERE'S TO AS
HE SAID AND I'M A CO PASTOR OF A
UNITED METHODIST CHURCH IN
SACRAMENTO WE CALL OURSELVES THE
TABLE.
AND IN OUR CHURCH IN SAC ARE
MANY FOSTER PARENTS AND FOSTER
CHILDREN --
FOSTER PROFESSIONALS IN THE
SYSTEM.
I MYSELF AM ACTUALLY AN ADOPTIVE
MOM NOT A FOSTER MOM --
MY FAMILY AS PART OF AN OPEN
ADOPTION --
AND WE ARE IN COMMUNITY WITH OUR
SON'S BIRTH MOM WHO HERSELF WAS
A PART OF THE CALIFORNIA FOSTER
SYSTEM.
AND OURS SON IN OUR FAMILY ARE A
PART OF AN OPEN ADOPTION WITH
HIS BIRTH SIBLINGS.
SOME TIME AGO I SERVED ON A
CONTINUUM OF CARE TEAM IN NAPA
COUNTY WHERE WE THEN LEFT WHICH
SUPPORTED FOSTER FAMILIES WHO
FOSTER TEENAGERS TO FIND WAYS.
TO COMMUNICATE AND BUILD TRUST
HIM VERY DIFFICULT AND
CHALLENGING CIRCUMSTANCES --
SO I KNOW THAT FOSTER TO TING
THE TRAUMA OF SEPARATION FROM
THEIR BIRTH FAMILIES FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS.
AND AS A UNITED METHODIST PASTOR
I BELIEVE ALL CHILDREN SHOULD BE
TREATED WITH RESPECT AND DIGNITY
REGARDLESS OF THEIR RACE OR
SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
GENDER IDENTITY OR THEIR
RELIGION.
IN ORDER FOR THE WORK OF OUR
CALIFORNIA FOSTER CARE SYSTEM TO
BE SUCCESSFUL I BELIEVE WE NEED
AN INTERSECTIONAL APPROACH WHICH
RECOGNIZES THAT.
BARRIERS --
DEBERRY YEARS THAT ARMED PEOPLE
EXPERIENCE AROUND RACE SEXUAL
ORIENTATION GENDER IDENTITY AND
RELIGION THAT CREATE CHALLENGES
FOR OUR PROFESSIONAL WORKERS AND
TO THOSE WHO SEEK. TO BE FOSTER
PARENTS.
SO AS A PASTOR SUPPORTING A LOT
OF FOSTER PARENTS AND CHILDREN I
BELIEVE IT IS IT --
OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO SUPPORT
THEM AT ESPECIALLY THE FOSTER
PARENTS TO PROVIDE THE BEST
LOVING AND STABLE ENVIRONMENT --
FOR THEIR FOSTER CHILD.
REGARDLESS OF WHO THE CHILD
IDENTIFIES AS OR WHAT THEY WOULD
LIKE TO BE CALLED I ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE WORK TOWARD
FULL INCLUSION FOR FOSTER YOUTH
IS VARIED.
AND VERY COMPLEX IS SO I AM.
DEEPLY IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
SEVENTY FIVE WHICH SEEKS TO
MODERNIZE THIS FOSTER YOUTH BILL
OF RIGHTS WHICH IS A WONDERFUL
THING -- SO
THAT IT ADDRESSES CURRENT KLAY
TO RECEIVE GROOMING AND HYGIENE
PRODUCTS REGARDLESS OF SEXUAL
ORIENTATION AND GENDER IDENTITY
AND I DON'T MEAN THIS AS A JOKE
BUT ALL TEENAGERS NEED GROOMING
AND HYGIENE PRODUCTS I HAVE
THREE TEENAGERS --
GOODNESS. TO ATTEND CULTURAL
ACTIVITIES CONSISTENT WITH OUR
IDENTITY.
AND TO BE REFERRED TO BY THEIR
PREFERRED NAMES AND THEIR GENDER
PRONOUNS AND I SAY THIS
RESPECTFULLY --
AND WITH PASSION THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME SERVE AS A
HERNANDEZ I'M THE DIRECTOR
POLICY FOR CALIFORNIA'S
CONNECTION.
SEE WE SEE THE EUCLID
ORGANIZATION OF CAR AND FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH ACROSS THE STATE.
MANY OF YOU HAVE MAYBE MY OUR
MEMBERS THROUGH SATURDAY OR ARE
ADVOCACY DAY AND WHAT'S UNIQUE
ABOUT SEE WE SEE IS THAT WE PUT
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE DRIVER'S
SEAT OF OUR POLICY PLATFORM.
A THE FIRST YOUTH BILL OF RIGHTS
SPECIFICALLY CAN BE CONSIDERED
ONE OF COS HE'S LEGACY PROJECTS
WE WERE THERE IN TWO THOUSAND
ONE WHEN IT WAS ORIGINATED --
ANOTHER BILL WE RAN WAS TO
CREATE THE FALSE KAREN BUT
OFFICE AND AGAIN IN PARTNERSHIP.
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON WHEN
WE UPDATED IT TWO YEARS AGO.
MY DO THIS HAS BEEN SEVERAL
GENERATIONS OF CIC MEMBERS WHO
HAVE ADVOCATED FOR THIS BILL OF
RIGHTS TO REFLECT WHAT RIGHTS
AND MANDATES ARE THERE TO
PROTECT THEM.
IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
SPECIFICALLY THE ORIGINS OF THE
FALLS TO THE BILL OF RIGHTS WERE
REALLY DESIGNED TO SUPPORT --
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE AND CONGREGATE
CARE AS WE KNOW WHAT THE MAJOR
C. C. R. REFORM THERE'S A BIG
PUSH FOR HOME BE SETTINGS --
BUT WE CAN WE MUST LOOK AT THE
SYSTEM HOLISTICALLY WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT POLICY SHIPS.
MY MEMBERS ARE EXCITED ABOUT THE
UPDATE UPDATED FALLS TO THE BILL
OF RIGHTS AS THEY HAVE FULLY
PARTICIPATED IN THE TWO YEAR
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS.
LED BY THE FOSTER CARE --
BUT OFFICE.
AND MY MEMBERS ARE CLEAR WHEN
THEY SAY THAT THEY DESERVE TO
KNOW THEIR RIGHTS --
IN A WAY THAT MAKES SENSE TO
THEM AND THAT IS AGE APPROPRIATE.
THEY ALSO SHARE THAT GROWING UP
IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM THERE
IS A LOT OF LOSS THERE'S GRIEF
BUT THERE'S ALSO POWER WHEN THEY
LEARN HOW TO NAVIGATE THE SYSTEM
BECOME.
AN ADULT THE COW YOUTH STUDY
STATES THAT 80% BETWEEN 8290% OF
YOUNG PEOPLE WANT TO GO TO
COLLEGE AND GO ON TO LIVE HAPPY
HEALTHY LIVES.
THIS IS HOW I EXPERIENCE MY
MEMBERS THEY ALSO SHARE THAT
HAVING A SUPPORT NETWORK EVEN
BETTER A FAMILY AS THE BEST WAY
TO SUPPORT THEM.
IN THAT QUALITY FOSTER PARENTS
WHO ARE UNDER THERE AND RESPECT
THEIR FULL IDENTITY IS ONE OF
THE BEST --
INTERVENTIONS THAT THE SYSTEM
CAN PROVIDE WITH THIS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU THIS GIPSON DO YOU
HAVE OTHER WITNESSES WORK NO
OKAY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME
AND YOUR AFFILIATION.
HEY I LET'S GET THE MICROPHONE
TURNED ON GOOD MORNING MR TURN
MEMBERS CONNIE DELGADO FOR THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
BECCA KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA ALSO
INSTANCE SUPPORT.
HELEN ROWLAND MEMBER OF THE
DAVIS UNITED METHODIST CHURCH
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BURSTING HEARST HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS AND SUPPORT.
N. MATTHEW SMITH --
UNITED METHODIST PASTOR IN
SUPPORT.
RENDON AWESOME PASSED TO THE
DAVIS UNITED METHODIST CHURCH IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT SING NONE OPPOSITION.
IF YOU COULD YOU CLEAR THE
TABLES PLEASE FOR THE FOLKS TO
COME UP.
THANKS [inaudible]
THE TEXT
.
MORNING THE MORNING ARE YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS --
MY NAME'S GREG BIRDS AND I WORK
FOR THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
COUNCIL.
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE SEVERAL
REASONS OUR ORGANIZATION IS
OPPOSING AB ONE SEVEN FIVE I'M
GONNA FOCUS ON THE PROVISION.
THAT GIVES FOSTER KIDS THE RIGHT
TO DEMAND THAT OTHERS USE THEIR
PRONOUN A PREFERENCE.
THE FIRST ISSUE IS OF MORALITY.
IT IS WRONG TO TEACH FOSTER KIDS
THAT THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO FORCE
OTHER PERSONS TO SAY WORDS THAT
THAT PERSON DOESN'T BELIEVE.
IN ANY OTHER CONTEXT THIS WOULD
BE UNTHINKABLE.
WHEN A CHILD OR EVEN ADULT TRIES
TO MAKE ANOTHER PERSON SAY
SOMETHING THAT CONTRADICTS THAT
PERSON'S BELIEF SYSTEM?
IT'S RUDE AND OBNOXIOUS.
BUT WHEN THE GOVERNMENT GETS
INVOLVED AND TRIES TO MANDATE
THE WORDS THAT COME OUT OF A
PERSON'S MOUTH.
IT'S TO RAN A COAL.
THE FIRST AMENDMENT DOES NOT NOT
ONLY PROTECTS OUR FREEDOM TO
SPEAK WORDS THE GOVERNMENT
DOESN'T LIKE.
BUT THE PROHIBITS THE GOVERNMENT
FROM COMPELLING US TO SAY WORDS
OR PROMOTE IDEAS WE DON'T
BELIEVE.
THIS COMMITTEE LEARNED THAT THE
HARD WAY LAST YEAR WHEN THE US
SUPREME COURT INVALIDATED ONE OF
ITS LAWS THIS COMMITTEE APPROVED
SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
HERE IS WHAT JUSTICE ANTHONY
KENNEDY SAID WHEN HE AND FOUR
OTHER JUSTICES STRUCK DOWN THE
REPRODUCTIVE FACT ACT.
AS UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
AND I QUOTE.
GOVERNMENTS MUST NOT BE ALLOWED
TO FORCE PERSONS TO EXPRESS THE
MESSAGE CONTRARY TO THEIR
DEEPEST CONVICTIONS.
FREEDOM OF SPEECH SECURES
FREEDOM OF THOUGHT AND BELIEF.
THIS LAW IN PERIL OF THOSE
LIBERTIES CLOSE QUOTE.
NO ONE WANTS TO BE FORCED TO SAY
WHAT THEY DO NOT BELIEVE.
WHEN YOU FORCE TRANSGENDER PRO
SOMEONE WHO BELIEVES THAT GENDER
IS BINARY?
AND DETERMINED BY BIOLOGY YOU
ARE COMPELLING SPEECH.
IT'S COMMON KNOWLEDGE THE
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT HAVE ENOUGH
FOSTER FAMILIES FOR THOSE
CHILDREN NEEDING THEM.
DURING THE LAST HEARING
ASSEMBLYMAN GIBSON ARGUE THAT
HIS BILL HAS AND I QUOTE GREAT
POTENTIAL OF INCREASING PARENTS
TAKING IN FOSTER CHILDREN
[inaudible]
REALLY.
COMMON SAYS SINCE WITH SAY THAT
THE OPPOSITE IS TRUE.
RULES LIKE THIS MAKE FOSTER
PARENTS THINK TWICE ABOUT TAKING
ON THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
FOSTERING.
AND THIS IS NOT FEAR MONGERING.
PEOPLE OF FAITH WANT TO LOVE AND
CARE FOR FOSTER CHILDREN AND
THIS BILL SENDS THE MESSAGE THAT
THEIR HELP IS NOT WANTED.
SO WE ASK THAT YOU PLEASE OPPOSE
AND VOTE NO ON AB ONE SEVEN FIVE
THINK SO MUCH.
THANK YOU BEFORE WE GO TO THE
NEXT WITNESS I'D LIKE TO
STARVATION FORM PLEASE STONE
HERE [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
CHAO YEAH CHIU.
GONZALEZ HOLDEN KALRA
[inaudible]
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS REYES.
THANK YOU N. AS I'D ALSO LIKE.
TO WELCOME OUR NEW VICE CHAIR MR
GALLAGHER AND MR OVER OBERNOLTE
WHO'S A NEW MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS OUR FIRST.
REGULAR HEARING AND A WE HAD ONE
OFF THE FLOOR EARLIER BUT
WELCOME TO THE NEW MEMBERS
[inaudible]
AND A APPRECIATE EVERYONE BEING
HERE I WOULD ALSO SINCE WE HAVE
THIS HOUSE FOR LIKE TO KNOW THAT
ITEM NUMBER FOUR A. B..
THREE TEN SANTIAGO HAS BEEN
PULLED FROM OUR AGENDA TODAY.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL CONTINUE WITH
HEARING ON THIS ITEM NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE --
MISTER CHAIRMAN MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S
KEVIN SNYDER A WITH PACIFIC
JUSTICE NSTITUTE CENTER FOR
PUBLIC POLICY OR I SERVICE CHIEF
COUNSEL.
THE BILL BEFORE YOU GIVES TEENS
UNFETTERED.
IN AN UNFETTERED RIGHT TO ATTEND
RELIGIOUS AND CULTURAL SERVICES
AND ACTIVITIES.
OF THEIR CHOICE.
SO IF A A YOUNG PERSON --
TELLS A FOSTER PARENT.
I DON'T WANT TO GO TO YOUTH
GROUP -- AND
NOTICE ONUS HE'S BEEN
RADICALIZED THROUGH THE HIS
THROUGH THE INTERNET WHICH IS A
NEW RIGHT.
ANY SAYS INSTEAD --
DROP ME OFF AT THE NORDIC TEMPLE
SO I COULD BE WITH PEOPLE OF
LIKE FAITH IN LIKE RACE.
THE BILL THIS BILL REQUIRES
FOSTER PARENTS TO LISTEN AND
OBEY THEIR TEAM.
THIS.
CAN BE RESOLVED AS DESCRIBED IN
THE LETTER THAT I SUBMITTED TO
THE COMMITTEE THROUGH AMENDMENT.
BUT THE BILL THEN TAKES A
CONSTITUTIONALLY PERILOUS TURN
BY WEAPONIZE IN AN ADOLESCENT
WITH THE FORCE OF LAW. TO COMPEL
UNWILLING ADULT THIRD PARTIES TO
REFER TO THIS TEENAGER BY
WHATEVER NAME OR PRONOUN THAT
THEY DESIRE. FOR EXAMPLE A
TEENAGE BOY COULD DIRECT A
FOSTER PARENT TO USE THE PRONOUN
THEY INSTEAD OF HE THIS IS
CONTENT BASED SPEECH.
THIS IS COMPELLED SPEECH.
JUST THIS LAST YEAR THE US
SUPREME COURT IN THE JANICE
DECISION MADE IT CLEAR THAT THE
GOVERNMENT CANNOT COMPEL
INDIVIDUALS TO MOUSE SUPPORT FOR
VIEWS THEY FIND [inaudible]
OBJECTIONABLE.
IF YOUR RELIGIOUS CONVICTIONS
SCIENCE OR THE LOGIC OF GRAMMAR
LEAD YOU TO BELIEVE THAT A MALE
IS THAT HE OR ONE PERSON IS NOT
THE A THE GOVERNMENT CANNOT
FORCE YOU. TO SAY SOMETHING YOU
KNOW TO BE DEMONSTRABLY FALSE.
IT IS AS ORWELLIAN IS FORCING
SOMEONE TO SAY TWO PLUS TWO
EQUALS.
FIVE SACRAMENTO NATIVE
[inaudible]
JUSTICE KENNEDY.
A WROTE PERHAPS THE LAST OPINION
THAT CAME FROM HIS PAN LAST YEAR --
ON THE REPRODUCTIVE FACT DECK.
IT WAS JUST QUOTED AND I'LL
QUOTED AGAIN FOR YOUR BENEFIT
GOVERNMENTS MUST NOT BE ALLOWED
TO FORCE PERSONS TO EXPRESS A
MESSAGE CONTRARY. TO THEIR
DEEPEST CONVICTIONS THAT WAS.
A OPINION IN A CONCURRENCE WHICH
I WOULD DIRECT YOU TO READ.
I WON'T ASK FOR SHOW OF HANDS
BUT SEVERAL OF YOU VOTED FOR THE
REPRODUCTIVE FACT ACT AND YOU
WERE WARNED THAT THAT WAS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
AND SO I WOULD SUGGEST THAT YOU
READ THAT OPINION.
YOUNG PEOPLE DO NOT NEED A BIG
BROTHER TO WRITE A LONG LIST OF
HOUSE PRIVILEGES THEY NEED
PARENTS WHO CAN PARENTS.
THEM THROUGH THE TURBULENCE OF
BEING A TEENAGER MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR DELIBERATION ON
THIS MATTER FOR YOUR SERVICE TO
THE COMMUNITY.
AND I URGE THE MEMBERS TO VOTE
NAY.
SECOND MOTION AND A SECONDS.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
IF YOU BECOME THE MICROPHONE
GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
ALL RIGHT SIGNALED A BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS.
SIR OBERNOLTE AND THE MISTER
KALRA.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF
MISTER GIBSON.
A QUESTION ABOUT THE PART OF THE
BILL THAT.
GIVES FOSTER YOUTH THE RIGHT TO
BE PLACED IN THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE SETTING POSSIBLE.
AND THERE'S NO DEFINITION OR
ELABORATION ON WHAT THAT MEANS
COULD YOU COULD YOU TELL US WHAT
YOUR INTENT WAS WITH THAT
SECTION BECAUSE I HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT IT.
GO AHEAD AND JUMP IN I'M PLEASE
RESPECT AT LEAST RESTRICTIVE
STUDYING IS --
ALLUDING TO CONGREGATE HOMES IN
INSTITUTIONS WHERE WE HAVE FOUND
THAT FOSTER YOUTH HAVE BEEN IN
THE HOUSE.
IN THE PAST WITH NO
JUSTIFICATION AND SO WHAT THE
CONTINUE OF CARE REFORM LEAST
RESTRICTIVE MEANS HOME BASED
WITH AL --
CURFEWS WITHOUT RULES AND
REGULATIONS THAT PROHIBIT THEIR
NORMAL LIVES AND SO WE FIND THIS
MOST IN GROUP HOMES SETTINGS
THIRTEEN AND FOURTEEN AN
INSTITUTIONAL --
INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE RESTRICTED
THEIR THEIR NORMAL ACTIVITIES SO
IT'S A SYNONYM FOR A HOME BASED
PLACEMENT.
OKAY.
I APPRECIATE THE CLARIFICATION I
WISH THEY BECAUSE I'M GONNA HAVE
TO BE IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL AND IT HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH THE LANGUAGE ABOUT
GENDER ORIENTATION IN THE BILL.
AND MORE TO DO WITH MY CONCERNS
THAT.
IF GOD FORBID MY CHILDREN
WHEREVER HE PLACED IN FOSTER
CARE I WOULD WANT THE FOSTER
PARENTS TO BE PARENTS.
CAN BEING A PARENT SOMETIMES
REQUIRES PLACING RESTRICTIONS ON
CHILDREN BECAUSE THEIR CHILDREN
AND THEY NEED TO BE GUIDED.
AND THE LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL
ABOUT.
THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE SETTING
AND THE LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL
ABOUT -- NOT
HAVING GIVING FOSTER PARENTS THE
RIGHT TO TAKE AWAY ACCESS TO
ACTIVITIES.
MAKES ME BELIEVE THAT IT A ROADS
THE FOSTER PARENTS ABILITY TO
PARENTS --
BUT I THANK YOU FOR THE ANSWER
THE QUESTION.
AND IF I MAY STEP IN --
THAT IS A PRETTY WELL
ESTABLISHED TERM IN.
THROUGH THAT PROCESS BOTH
FEDERAL LAW AND STATE LAW AND
RULES AND REGULATIONS IN FACT
ALL THIS BILL REALLY DOES.
ISN'T CAPULET CAPS LATE EXISTING
LAW.
EXISTING REGULATIONS AND
PRACTICES AT DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES SO THE TERMS
THAT ARE USED IN HERE ARE IN
THIS REALM PRETTY WELL DEFINED
IN PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD.
I'LL HAVE TO RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE WITH YOU MISTER CHAIR
THE WASN'T CLEAR TO ME ON A
PLAIN LANGUAGE READING OF THE
BILL THAT THAT'S WHAT LEAST
RESTRICTIVE SETTING THAT.
OKAY IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
ANALYSIS I THINK IT'S FAIRLY
CLEAR AND IF YOU LIKE I CAN GET
YOU MORE RESOURCES ON THE THE
THE LAW WITH HER OUR SYSTEM.
WHERE THIS IS VERY HEAVILY
CODIFIED?
I THINK OF USEFUL THANK YOU SURE
A MISTER KALRA.
THANK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK SUMMER GIPSON --
I I KNOW WAS WORK ON FOSTER
YOUTH ISSUES THE ENTIRE TIME
HE'S BEEN IN THE LEGISLATURE AND
ALL THIS IS A CONTINUE TO A PART
OF THAT WORK --
TO ENSURE THAT WERE SUPPORTING
OUR FOSTER YOUTH WHO WILL BE ALL
KNOW HAVE --
MANY CHALLENGES AND I BELIEVE
DESERVE --
SUPPORTIVE --
ENVIRONMENTS THAT --
VALIDATE WHO THEY ARE --
AND YOU KNOW.
I I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OF FOR THEIR FOR THEIR TESTIMONY
AND YOU KNOW IF SOMEONE CANNOT.
SUPPORT UP ANY YOUTH AND AND I
THINK THAT --
I APPRECIATE --
BUT THE THE WORK THAT
LEGISLATORS DONE PEOPLE PRIOR TO
MEET MY COME HERE BUT EVEN THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS.
IN RECOGNIZING THE THE
CHALLENGES OF BEING OF AUSTRIA.
AND OFTENTIMES PARTICULARLY --
LGBT Q. --
YOUTH ARE THE ONES THAT HAVE --
DIFFICULTY --
IN FOSTER PLACEMENTS BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT ACCEPTED WITH A ARE
AND HAVE A MUCH GREATER
LIKELIHOOD OF OF ENDING UP
HOMELESS --
ANY UP IN THE PROMOTE JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND THE A BEING VICTIMS
AND WITHIN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM AS WELL AND SO I THINK
THAT IT DOES REQUIRE US TO TAKE --
EXTRA STEPS TO ENSURE THEIR
SAFETY AND ENSURE THAT WERE
SUPPORTING GIVE THEM ONCE AGAIN
FOR WHO THEY ARE AND I WANT TO
THANK A ASSEMBLY GIPSON COMING
THIS BEFORE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE STAFF.
I JUST HAVE A QUICK QUESTION ON
THE ENFORCEMENT COMPONENT SO
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF OF PUBLIC
SERVICES --
BE THE AND FORCING AGENCY IN
THIS PARTICULAR CASE OR ALL OF
THE CASES YES [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THIS GALLAGHER.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
SO.
ASSUMING GIPSON A NOTE WE SHARE
A PASSION FOR FOSTER USE AND AND
CERTAINLY IN TRYING TO ENSURE
THAT -- YOU
KNOW WE PROVIDE.
A GOOD EXPERIENCE FOR FOSTER USE
THAT -- THAT
WE KNOW THERE HAS BEEN PROBLEMS --
IN THE PAST --
ABUSES -- I
GUESS ONE OF MY CAN SELL START
UNUSUALLY MY CONCERN IS I KNOW
YOU'VE BEEN IN CLOSE CONTACT
WITH THE GROUP.
OF THE STAKEHOLDER GROUP IN THAT
PROCESS BUT NONE THE LESS THE
PROCESS IS NOT DONE YET IT'S NOT
COMPLETED.
AND I THINK IT BE KINDA BE
PUTTING THE CART BEFORE THE
HORSE BEFORE WE HAD THAT FULL
REPORT BACK.
AS TO YOU KNOW WHAT WE SHOULD DO
IN TERMS OF UPDATING THE FOSTER
CARE BILL OF RIGHTS --
I ALSO THINK IS HAS BEEN AS IT'S
BEEN POINTED OUT AND I DON'T SEE
ANY REASON WHY WE COULDN'T.
PUT THE SOFT ON NEXT YEAR ONCE
WE HAVE THE REPORT IN FRONT OF
US AND WE CAN EVERYBODY CAN GO
THROUGH THAT --
BUT I ALSO THINK IT'S BEEN
POINTED OUT SOME OF THESE THINGS --
YOU KNOW COULD BE INTERPRETED
AWAY THE INTERFERES WITH THE
ABILITY OF A FOSTER PARENT. TO
BE A PARENT.
WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT WE WANT --
WE DO WANT ARE FOSTER PARENTS
[inaudible]
TO YOU KNOW [inaudible]
BY A A GOOD PLACE --
FOR FOR A FOSTER USE --
BUT PART OF THAT IS IS IS.
IS BEING ABLE TO PARENT THE WAY
THAT YOU.
SEE FIT FOR THAT CHILD --
WHICH COULD INCLUDE RESTRICTIONS
ON YOU KNOW TIME USING THE
INTERNET.
WHICH COULD INCLUDE I MEAN NOT
EVERYONE HAS TO GIVE AN
ALLOWANCE.
HE I MEAN CERTAIN SAYING THESE
THINGS ARE RIGHT --
WHEN YOU KNOW THERE'S?
HERE'S DEFINITELY THINGS THAT
COULD BE A REASONABLE USE OF A
PARENT UTILIZING THEIR AUTHORITY
IN TRYING TO ESTABLISH
BOUNDARIES AND TRYING --
TO YOU PROVIDE THAT STRUCK --
THAT I THINK ALL OF US.
THOSE OF US WHO WHO ARE HERE AS
PARENTS.
DO OURSELVES YOU KNOW AND SO.
WHY WOULD WE KIND OF EXPECT
SOMETHING DIFFERENT? FOR FOSTER
PARENTS AND WE WOULD EXPECT --
THEN WE WOULD EXPECT OF
OURSELVES AS PARENTS.
PARENTING OUR OWN CHILDREN --
SO I THINK WE NEED TO REALLY
THINK ABOUT THAT BEFORE WE JUST
ESTABLISHED THIS IS SOME SORT OF
RIGHT -- AND
I THINK WITH WITH WITH REGARD TO
THE GENDER IDENTITY ISSUE I KNOW
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY SOMETHING IS
VERY SENSITIVE. TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE --
BUT THERE ARE CASES WHERE YOU
KNOW WHERE THERE'S GENDER
DYSPHORIA AND AND THAT ACTUALLY --
THE CHILD ENDS UP GOING BY THEIR
BIOLOGICAL SEX BY THE TIME THEY
REACH ADULTHOOD --
AND SO.
AND THERE MAY BE ISSUES WE KNOW
THAT FOSTER USE DEAL WITH A LOT
OF ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES
AS WE KNOW ACES --
THERE COULD BE A YOU KNOW OTHER
THINGS GOING ON THAT IS PART OF
A COUNSELING --
REGIMEN AS PART OF SUPPORTING
THAT USE IN GETTING THROUGH THIS
THEY MAY HANDLE THAT DIFFERENTLY
THAN.
SAY THE PEOPLE ON THIS COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU SHOULD HANDLE THAT.
AND YOU KNOW I DON'T REALLY
THINK THAT THAT'S OUR PLACE TO
DETERMINE.
YOU KNOW YOU KNOW WHAT NAMES YOU
SHOULD USE.
YOU HOW YOU SHOULD DEAL WITH
THAT SITUATION AND A AND IT I
THINK IT IS VERY SPECIFIC TO THE
CHILD THAT'S INVOLVES NOT EVERY
CHILD IS THE SAME WE ALL KNOW
THAT WE ALL SAY THAT --
BUT WE SEEM TO HAVE A PROBLEM.
DOING THAT IN PRACTICE WHEN
WE'RE WHEN WE'RE PASSING LAW --
SO YOU KNOW I JUST THINK THAT AT
THIS TIME APPOINTED TIME WITH
WHERE THIS BILLS THAT IT'S
PREMATURE AND I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF THINGS THAT NEED TO BE
WORKED THROUGH --
THAT COULD ACTUALLY IMPEDE.
THE ABILITY OF OF FOSTER PARENTS
TO PROVIDE THAT.
THAT SAVE SPACE THAT STRUCTURED
SPACE THAT PLACE IS GOING TO
BRING THIS CHILD TO ADULTHOOD.
AND INTO A PRODUCTIVE LIFESTYLE
LONG TERM --
AND SO I KNOW WE DON'T WANT TO
DO THAT.
AND THAT'S WHY I WOULD JUST SAY
HEY I THINK THIS ME SOME MORE
TIME NEED SOME MORE DISCUSSION.
AND I YOU KNOW CAN'T BE
SUPPORTER OF IT IN ITS CURRENT
FORM.
HI THANK YOU MISTER GIBSON FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I WOULD
POINT OUT TO THE COMMITTEE THAT
IF YOU LOOK AT THE ANALYSIS
EVERYONE OF THE RIGHTS THAT'S
LISTED.
HAS A STATUTORY OR REGULATORY
REFERENCE ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
THERE IS NOTHING IN THIS BILL
THAT ESTABLISHES ANY NEW RIGHTS.
OR OBLIGATIONS THEY ARE ENTIRELY
EXISTING IN CALIFORNIA LAW THE
VALUE OF THIS STATEMENT.
AND WHY A THERE'S NOT A QUESTION
OF CONSTITUTIONALITY WHERE
THERE'S NOT A QUESTION THAT WERE
IMPOSING ANYTHING.
IS THAT IT IS A VERY.
CLEAR SO FOR FOSTER KIDS TO BE
ABLE TO SEE WHERE THEIR RIGHTS
ARE ENUMERATED BECAUSE THEY
ALREADY EXIST IN STATUTE EXISTED
REGULATION.
THERE'S NOTHING NEW IN HERE SO I
DON'T SEE ANY REASON WHY THEY
SHOULD MOVE FORWARD I DON'T SEE
WHY.
WE NEED TO WAIT FOR ANYTHING IN
ADDITION I THINK YOU'VE DONE A
VERY GOOD JOB WITH THIS MISTER
GIBSON THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
ALL RIGHT MISTER GALLAGHER.
I MEAN IF IF I MIGHT --
YOU KNOW WE HAVE SOME GREAT
PEOPLE UP HERE WHO DO ANALYSES
AND AND AND MY GIVE THEM A LOT
OF CREDIT FOR WHAT THEY PUT
TOGETHER BUT AN ANALYSIS OF THE
COMMITTEE IS NOT LIKE THE END
ALL BE ALL.
AND HEY THAT'S THE FINAL ANSWER --
NO AND AND I GUESS THE OTHER
PART WOULD BE.
YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW IF THIS IS TRUE THAT IS
ALL STATUTORY REGULATORY THAN
THAT WOULD NEGATE THE NEED FOR
THE BILL.
BECAUSE OF ITS ALREADY IF IT'S
ALREADY ESTABLISHED LAW WHY ARE
WE DOING ANOTHER LAW. TO JUST
REPEAT THAT I SUSPECT THAT
THAT'S ACTUALLY NOT THE CASE AND
THAT'S WHY I'M MANY OF THE
CONCERNS BEEN REYES AGAIN IF YOU
LOOK AT THE ANALYSIS AND I'M NOT
SAYING THE ANALYSIS IS IS WHAT
ESTABLISHES THAT.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT EACH OF THE
PROVISIONS.
THAT ARE LAID OUT IN IT IS KEYED
TO EXISTING STATUTES OR SIZE YOU
WOULD NEED TO GO READ THE
STATUTES AND EACH REGULATORY
REFERENCE TO UNDERSTAND WHERE
ALL OF THE PROVISIONS ARE.
AND GIVEN THAT THERE IS A LACK
OF UNDERSTANDING EVEN HERE OF
THE CONNECTIVITY TO THE
STATUTORY FRAMEWORK INTO THE
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK THINK HOW.
DIFFICULT THAT IS FOR A FOSTER
CHILD TO NAVIGATE.
THE VALUE OF THIS BILL THE VALUE
OF THIS STATEMENT OF FOSTER
CHILD'S BILL OF RIGHTS IS SO
THAT IS CLEARLY PUT IN ONE PLACE.
FOR REFERENCE THIS IS A DOCUMENT
THAT WOULD BE PROVIDED.
TO FOSTER CHILDREN WHO ARE IN
THE CARE OF THE STATE.
SO THAT THEY AT LEAST HAVE A
CLEAR STATEMENT THAT OF WHAT
THEIR RIGHTS ARE THEY CAN PURSUE
THAT.
IF OTHERWISE NECESSARY BUT
THERE'S NOTHING REALLY IN HERE
THAT'S NOT ALWAYS ALREADY WELL
ESTABLISHED MR.
TO THANK YOU.
I WASN'T GOING TO SPEAK ON THIS
BUT FIRST WELL GLAD TO HAVE
MISTER GALLAGHER BACK IN THE
COMMITTEE --
AND I WOULD LIKE --
TO TO SAY A FEW THOUGHTS ON THIS.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT THE
AUTHOR IS ADDRESSING THE REALITY --
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
CHILDREN WHO OPPORTUNITY TO BE
WHO THEY ARE --
I DISCUSS THIS BILL WITH MY WIFE
LAST NIGHT SHE MANAGES A FOSTER
CARE PROGRAM AND SHE WILL TELL
YOU.
AND THE COMMUNITY OF FOLKS WHO
WORK WITH FOSTER CARE CARE
CHILDREN WILL TELL YOU JUST HOW
MUCH INCREDIBLE HURT THERE HAS
ALREADY BEEN --
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT
CHILDREN CONTINUE TO BE DENIED
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE WHO THEY
ARE AND THE SUGGESTION THAT WE
SHOULD NOT ADDRESS THAT AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN --
IT IS ONE THAT I SIMPLY DISAGREE
WITH I ALSO WANNA JUST TAKE THE
MOMENT I KNOW THERE WERE SOME
REFERENCE TO SUGGEST THAT THE
SUPREME COURT.
HAS WAITED ON THIS IS AND I
THINK ARE THE OPPONENTS OF THIS
BILL WOULD KNOW THAT BILL WAS IN
A VERY DIFFERENT CONTEXT I DON'T
THINK ONE COULD SAY --
THAT THE CONTEXT OF THE NEW FLU
DECISION HAS ANYTHING TO DO WITH
THE SUBJECT THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY.
AND I WOULD ALSO SAY --
RESPECTING THE PERSPECTIVE THAT
IS BROUGHT BY THE OPPONENTS I
KNOW -- IT
COMES FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE OF
WHAT IT MEANS TO BE CHRISTIAN I
WOULD JUST SAY AS A CHURCH GOING
CHRISTIAN [inaudible]
MYSELF.
THE GREATEST COMMANDMENT THAT WE
HAVE IS TO LOVE AND I THINK
FUNDAMENTALLY THIS BILL IS ABOUT.
IS ABOUT SAYING THAT WE RESPECT
AND LOVE CHILDREN THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM AND WE WANT THEM. TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE WHO
THEY WANT WITH THAT.
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
I'M ALSO HAPPY TO BE ADDED ON AS
A CO AUTHOR OF THAT SOMETHING
THE AUTHOR WOULD WOULD WOULD
WOULD LIKE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU SEE GETTING MY
CLOTHES THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CERTAINLY I
HAVE --
LISTEN LISTENED ATTENTIVELY AND
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION AROUND THIS BILL
WANT TO CLARIFY A FEW THINGS --
ONE BEING THAT --
YOU KNOW WITH INDIVIDUALS OF
COOPER FAST THEIR FAITH IS BEING
CHRISTIANS --
ARE WE FISHERMAN'S OF MAN AND
NOT AQUARIUM KEEPERS.
AQUARIUM KEEPERS VERY SELECTIVE.
OF THE FISH THAT THEY PUT INTO
OF C<c.cyan> OUT OF KOREA.</c>
BUT A FISH MAN A MAN IS WHATEVER
YOU CATCH.
YOU BRING IN.
AND IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
FOSTER HOME.
IF A FOSTER PARENT CHOOSES TO BE
A FOSTER PARENT AND BRING THAT
CHILD IN.
I'M HOPING THAT THAT CHILD WILL
RECEIVE THE SAME KIND OF SUPPORT
LOVE --
GUIDANCE IN WHICH WE GIVE OUR
OWN BIOLOGICAL CHILDREN.
I'M HOPING THAT YOU KNOW ONE WE
WOULD NOT HAVE TO CODIFY CERTAIN
THINGS IN LAW --
IF THEY WORK BEING DONE SO RIGHT
NOW AND FOSTER HOME.
WE TALK ABOUT IN THIS BILL HI
GENE.
GROOMING.
IT'S INDICATION THAT THAT'S NOT
HAPPENING IN SOME OF THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM SO FOSTER HOMES THAT
WE HAVE TODAY OR WE IT WOULDN'T
BE NECESSARY FOR US TO PUT THAT
IN THE BILL.
TODAY AND SO WE THESE ARE RIGHTS
THAT WE'RE SAYING THAT.
MAKING SURE THAT OUR CHILDREN
KNOW THESE INELIGIBLE RIGHTS
THAT THEY HAVE MAKE SURE THE
SOCIAL WORKER UNDERSTAND ABOUT
THE RIGHTS OF THEIR CHILDREN
WHEN THEY PLACING THESE CHILDREN
INTO THE BOSTON IN A FOSTER HOME.
WE WANT TO PROVIDE CHILDREN WHO
ALREADY HAVE TRAUMA --
BUT OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE A NEW
NARRATIVE A NEW NARRATIVE TO
GROW UP TO BE YOU KNOW CITIZENS
WILL BE WHO EVER THEY CHOOSE TO
BE AND IDENTIFY WITH WHICH IS
STILL LOVE THEM REGARDLESS.
IF MY SON SAYS DAD I'M GET LOVE
MY SON UNCONDITIONALLY WHY
BECAUSE MY FATHER LOVE ME
UNCONDITIONALLY.
IN THE MIDST OF ALL MY FLAWS AND
PITFALLS THE WHOLE NINE YARDS WE
HAVE THE LOVE EVEN THOSE WHO ARE
OUR FOSTER KIDS WHO HAVE GONE
THROUGH TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCE.
AND WE'RE GOING TO SAY WE DON'T
ACCEPT THEM WE SHOULD ACCEPT
THEM AS THEY ARE AND NOT PUSH
THEM ASIDE.
AND BE REALLY FISHERMAN'S OF MEN
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THAT MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
GALLAGHER.
BURGER NO CHAO CHAO AYE CHIU AYE
CHIU AYE GONZALEZ HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO PETRIE-NORRIS REYES.
THE BILL HAS FIVE NEEDS TO MORE
SO WE ARE WE WILL PUT ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU WE
ALSO HEARD A. B. FOR TWENTY FOUR
ITEM NUMBER SIX FROM MR GABRIEL
I'LL TAKE A MOTION.
THERE'S A MOTION AND A SECOND
THAT MOTION IS DO PASS.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
CHOW.
CHOW I CHOOSE. TO AYE GONZALEZ
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I FUTURE NORRIS REYES
THAT BILLS ON CALL WE NEED ONE
MORE VOTE.
WE ALSO HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA
[inaudible]
OKAY.
I AM TOLD THAT ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
AB THREE TWENTY SEVEN HAS BEEN
PULLED FROM THE CONSENT AGENDA.
SO WE WILL HEAR THAT BILL.
TODAY AND WE'RE THIS MAY TURN
YOU YOU PREPARED.
TO DO THAT TODAY ALL RIGHT.
SO THAT IS NO LONGER ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA I WILL THEN TAKE
A MOTION ON THE REVISED CONSENT
AGENDA.
THERE IS A MOTION AND A SECOND.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
STONE BY STONE AYE GALLAGHER
CHAU CHOI CHU. TWO I GONZALEZ
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE AND PETRIE-NORRIS
REYES.
SO THE CONSENT AGENDA IS ON CALL.
ALL RIGHT --
MR MANGE I WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT
TO WILL MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN WHICH IS AB [inaudible]
THREE TWENTY SEVEN MISS
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
SURPRISE SURPRISE.
I GUESS NOT.
HI GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB THREE TWENTY SEVEN
MAKES A SIMPLE CLARIFICATION IN
LAW BY ADDING A NEW SECTION OF
THE PROBATE CODE. TO ELIMINATE
AMBIGUITY BECAUSE BY THE LET'S
CASE IN TWENTY FOURTEEN THE CASE
OF LANCE VERSUS LANCE HELD THAT
SPOUSAL AT DEATH DONATED
TRANSFERS.
ARE SUBJECT TO THE OBLIGATIONS
IMPOSED UNDER THE FAMILY CODE
THAT'S CREATING AN AUTOMATIC
PRESUMPTION OF UNDUE INFLUENCE
FOR SPOUSAL AT DEATH DONUT OF
TRANSFERS.
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES THAT
FAMILY CODE SECTION SEVEN TWENTY
ONE DOES NOT CREATE A
PRESUMPTION OF UNDUE INFLUENCE
WHEN ONE SPOUSE NAMES THE OTHER
SPOUSE AS A BENEFICIARY.
OF A VOCAL TRUST OR OTHER
INSTRUMENT MAKING IT DOWN INTO
TRANCE ARE ON DEATH.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OUR IT ARE THE CALIFORNIA
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION.
GOOD MORNING MR NUMBERS VINCE
WHAT MADRE WITH WIDENING GROUP
HERE ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION --
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SIGNAL BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
THANK YOU THOUGH --
THIS MAY TELL YOU MAY CLOSE I
THANK YOUR RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN IRA.
THANK YOU.
SO THAT THE MOTION IS DO PASS
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE GALLAGHER CHOW.
CHOW I CHU CHU AYE GONZALEZ
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN I MEAN CHEN
AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE I
PETRIE-NORRIS REYES.
THE BILL NEEDS ONE MORE SO WE
PUT OUR CALL THANK YOU MISTER
THANK YOU.
WE DO NOT CURRENTLY HAVE AUTHORS
MR TING HAS ASKED ME TO PRESENTS
AB.
FIFTY FOUR SO I'M GOING TO DO
THAT MR HOLDEN WOULD YOU.
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
.
FOR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF MR TING I
WOULD LIKE TO PRESENTS.
AB FIFTY FOUR THERE WAS A
DRAFTING ERROR LAST YEAR IN AB
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT PRIOR TO ITS
IMPLEMENT AND MADE A BEFORE
SEVENTY EIGHT WHICH WAS SIGNED
BY.
GOVERNOR BROWN.
BECAUSE OF THAT ERA MISTER
TAKING COMMITTED TO ADDRESSING
THAT ISSUE AND FIXING THAT HERE
THAT'S WHY THIS BILLS BEFORE ITS
WIDE IS URGENCY.
AND FACTS.
AB SEVEN FORTY EIGHT WILL NOT
TAKE EFFECT UNTIL JULY ONE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN SO IF WE IF
THIS DOES MOVE THROUGH ON ITS
URGENCY BASIS.
THIS HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
PUT INTO LAW FIX THE AIR BEFORE.
THE UNDERLYING POLICY COMES INTO
A FACT AND WHAT THE EXISTING
WHAT THIS POLICY WILL DO THAT
THE UNDERLYING BILL HAS TO DO
WITH.
BODY CAMERA IMAGES AND THIS
WOULD ALLOW A DELAY IN
DISCLOSURE [inaudible]
PENDING A AN INCIDENT THAT WOULD
SUBSTANTIALLY OR IF THAT
DISCLOSURE WOULD SUBSTANTIALLY
INTERFERE WITH ONGOING
INVESTIGATIONS.
WE DO HAVE.
FOLKS IN SUPPORT AND I WILL TURN
IT OVER TO THE WITH THIS THANK
YOU.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED TO
REGISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
JIMMY WHAT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
NEWS PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL --
AND NOW MORE THAN EVER WE KNOW.
AS LITIGATION CONTINUES.
TO PURSUE IN THE COURTS OVER AS
SURE THAT YOU LAST YEAR PAST --
DEALING WITH ACCESS TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL RECORDS --
THAT CLARIFYING A STATUTE IS
INDEED VERY IMPORTANT WE HEAR
DRIVE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
TURN MEMBERS KEVIN BAKER FOR THE
AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION
OF CALIFORNIA ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
FIXING THE STEP A GRAPHICAL
ERROR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY --
ANYONE FROM THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
THE BILL.
ANYONE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS IS
THERE A MOTION.
IS THERE MOTION OKAY --
SO MR STONE IS THERE ANYTHING
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE ON I WAS
REALLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON
BEHALF MISTER TING THANK YOU
OKAY --
CALDERON.
MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS STONE.
BY STONE AYE GALLAGHER CHOW.
CHOW I CHU.
CHU AYE GONZALEZ HOLDEN AYE
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN HI MAIENSCHEIN
I OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE I'D
PETRIE-NORRIS RACE [inaudible]
OKAY.
SO THAT BILL NEEDS ONE MORE VOTE
IT IS ALSO ON CALL.
WHEN HE STAYS WILL --
BUT MORE PROGRESS TO THE ACTUAL
DATA THANK YOU.
MISTER CARR I BELIEVE IS ON HIS
WAY WE HAVE TO MORE BILLS TO
HEAR.
AND BUSINESS ALSO BELIEVE IS
PRESENTING ANOTHER BILL.
I'M NOT SURE WHEN WE'LL SEE HERE
MISTER KALRA.
WELCOME WILL MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB. FOR EIGHTEEN OH BY THE
WAY THE CONSENT AGENDA THE BILL
THAT WAS PASSED THERE WAS AB.
THREE TWENTY EIGHT WHICH IS
MISTER MAIENSCHEIN SPELL
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AB FOR EIGHTEEN WOULD ESTABLISH
EVIDENTIARY PRIVILEGE PROHIBIT
THE DISCLOSURE OF CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATIONS MAY BETWEEN
EMPLOYEE AND THERE YOU
REPRESENTATIVE.
PRIVILEGES AN EXCLUSIONARY RULE
OF EVIDENCE THAT PROTECTS
CERTAIN CLASSES OF
COMMUNICATIONS FROM DISCLOSURE
TO OPPOSING PARTIES AT FROM
ENTRY INTO EVIDENCE IN LEGAL
PROCEEDINGS.
THE RATIONALE IS THAT ALTHOUGH
CERTAIN INFORMATION MAY BE
RELEVANT IT IS NONETHELESS
EXCLUDED BECAUSE OF OVERRIDING
SOCIAL INTERESTS.
THE CALIFORNIA EVIDENCE CODE
CURRENTLY CONTAINS A NUMBER OF
SPECIFIC PRIVILEGES FOR CERTAIN
COMMUNICATIONS INCLUDING COMMON
PRIVILEGES BETWEEN ATTORNEY AND
CLIENT OR POSITION AND PATIENT.
ALTHOUGH IT IS UNFORTUNATE --
MANY WORKERS A FACE WHICH IS A
DISCRIMINATION EXPORTER IN.
A PLEASE ASSUME THAT SUCH
COMMUNICATIONS DISCUSS WITH
THEIR OFFICIAL YOU
REPRESENTATIVE IS CONFIDENTIAL
AND THAT INFORMATION MAY NOT BE
DISCLOSED THE EMPLOYER OR OTHER
THIRD PARTIES.
HOWEVER NO STATUS TO A STATUE
PROVIDE SUCH COMMUNICATIONS WITH
AN EVIDENTIARY PRIVILEGE NORRIS
CASE I RECOGNIZE SUCH A
PRIVILEGE.
THIS EXTENDS TO INSTANCES OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT HARASSMENT AND
DISCRIMINATION WHERE EMPLOYEE
PREFERS TO APPROACH HIS OR HER
HE REPRESENTATIVE RATHER THAN
HUMAN RESOURCES DEPARTMENT.
IN REPRESENTATIVES ARE IMPORTANT
THIRD PARTY WHEN THERE IS REASON
TO BELIEVE THAT THE EMPLOYER
DOES NOT HAVE THE BEST INTERESTS
OF THE EMPLOYEE.
IN MIND.
DURING THAT TIME --
WERE DISCRIMINATORY AN
UNFORTUNATE EVENTS OCCUR IN THE
WORKPLACE ADDITIONAL
CONFIDENTIAL AVENUES TO REPORT
THESE INSTANCES ARE IN GREATER
NEED.
BY ALLOWING EVIDENTIARY
PRIVILEGED TO WORKERS AND YOU
REPRESENTATIVES WE CAN HELP TO
ENSURE THE SAFE PRIVATE AND FULL
DISCLOSURE OF WORKPLACE CONCERNS
AND NEEDS.
AND WITH WHAT'S HAPPENING AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL WITH THE EROSION
OF WORKERS RIGHTS AS BOTH A AND
WASHINGTON DC BUT THE GOP
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS THE
SUPREME COURT.
I THINK IT'S MORE IMPORTANT THAN
EVER THAT WE ALLOW FOR AVENUES
FOR WORKERS TO HAVE GREATER
PROTECTIONS AS WELL AS THE UIT
PRESENT LIVES THAT THAT WORK
CLOSELY WITH THEM TO PROTECT
THEIR RIGHTS.
WOULD BE UP BY SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY IRVINE ALISON --
POLITICAL LET'S SAY DIRECTOR.
OF OVER ASKED ME --
REPRESENT REPRESENTATION
SPECIALS THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU FIRST WITH US PLEASE.
WITH THE CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BRIGHT HOUSE IN ABOUT
HALF THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
I'LL KEEP MY COMMENTS INCREDIBLY
PRE FIGHT JUST LIKE TO THANK THE
MEMBER FOR TAKE A TAKEN ON THIS
VERY IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION ALSO LIKE TO
INTRODUCE MICHAEL SEVILLE.
ARE FROM --
APPS ME DISTRICT COUNCIL FIFTY
SEVEN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR TO
PROVIDE SUBSTANTIVE TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU NEXT WITH THIS PLEASE
MORNING MR CHAIR MICHAEL SEVILLE
WITH APPS ME COUNCIL --
FIFTY SEVEN PROBABLY
REPRESENTING YOUR THIRTY
THOUSAND WORKERS AT THE STATE --
CITY COUNTY UTILITY IN TRANSIT
AND EDUCATION DISTRICTS I TOO
WANT TO THANK.
OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
SPONSORING THIS BILL IN JUST ONE
HIT ON A COUPLE POINTS.
THAT HE MADE IN HIS OPENING
REMARKS --
HE IS RIGHT THAT WORKERS ARE
UNDER ATTACK AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL --
BOTH COMING OUT OF CONGRESS AND
THE SUPREME COURT WE SEE DALY
DELUSIONS AYE WHAT WHETHER IT'S
AT THE ADMINISTRATIVE LEVEL
THROUGH THE NLRB.
OR THE COURTS HANDING DOWN RULES
FURTHER WE NEED THESE
PROTECTIONS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WE'VE SEEN AN EXPLOSION OF
LITIGATION IN THE POST --
JANICE WORLD --
EVERY DAY WERE CONFRONTED WITH
THE EXCITING AND VERY IMPORTANT
ME TO MOVEMENT AND GIVING
WORKERS --
THIS SENSE OF CONFIDENTIALITY
AND THE TRUST THAT THEIR
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEIR UNION
AGENTS.
WON'T BE USED AGAINST THEM ARE
DISCLOSED --
IN IN A JUDY COULD OF OR
JUDICIAL --
PROCESS HAS NEVER BEEN MORE
IMPORTANTTO GIVE WORKERS THAT
FREEDOM TO TALK ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON AT THE WORKPLACE AND
TRUST THAT NO IT WILL BE USED
AGAINST THEM IN ANY OTHER WAY IF
THEY DISCLOSE CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION THAT THE EMPLOYER
HAS NO RIGHT TO KNOW.
SECONDLY NOTHING IN THIS BILL
CHANGES THE EMPLOYER'S ABILITY
TO CONDUCT WORKPLACE
INVESTIGATIONS.
NOTHING THEY CAN STILL CONDUCT
ALL OF THE INVESTIGATIONS JUST
AS THEY DO NOW WITH THIS BILL.
THEY'RE ALLOWED TO CALL
WITNESSES THEY'RE ALLOWED TO
INVESTIGATE THE ALLOWED TO ASK
QUESTIONS NOTHING PREVENTS OR
PROHIBITS THEM FROM DOING THAT
AND ALLOWS AN EMPLOYEE TO REFUSE
TO ANSWER A QUESTION THAT IS
DIRECTLY ASKED.
BY THE EMPLOYER THEY SIMPLY HAVE
TO CONDUCT THEIR OWN
INVESTIGATIONS.
AND THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO A
QUICKLY MAKE CHAIR IS THAT.
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN A UNION
AND A REPRESENTED EMPLOYEE IS
UNIQUE.
UNIONS HAVE UNDER THE LAW HAVE A
DUTY KNOWN AS THE DUTY OF FAIR
REPRESENTATION TO CONDUCT
WORKPLACE INVESTIGATIONS AND
REPRESENT OUR MEMBERS AND
REPRESENT EMPLOYEES TO THE
FULLEST --
EXTENT OF OUR CAPACITY THAT
MEANS WE HAVE TO ASK QUESTIONS
THAT MEANS THAT INFORMATION MAY
JUST BE DISCLOSED DURING THAT
PROCESS AGAIN THAT WERE LEGALLY
OBLIGATED --
TO IT HERE.
TO THAT SHOULD NOT BE --
FORCED TO BE TURNED OVER TO THE
EMPLOYER --
AND IN A JUDY COULD EVER
JUDICIAL SETTING AND I AGAIN I
THINK THIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
DOING THIS BECAUSE I THINK THIS
IS A BIG POINT THAT THERE IS A
UNIQUE RELATIONSHIP --
THAT GOES ON WHEN WE RECEIVE A
SUBPOENA BEEN DOING THIS FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS I'M AN ATTORNEY
I'VE DONE THIS IN PRIVATE
PRACTICE AND I CAN'T TELL YOU
WHEN WE GET A SUBPOENA FROM AN
EMPLOYER AND A CASE THAT.
THE IN THE UNION CONDUCTS AN
INVESTIGATION IT'S DECIDED THAT
IS A BETTER TO MOVE IT AND A
QUARTER SOMETHING GET A SUBPOENA
FOR THE EMPLOYER AND HAVETO
TURN OVER THE INTERNAL NOTES AND
COMMUNICATIONS THAT WERE MADE
BETWEEN.
THE WORKER AND THE UNION AGENT --
IS DEVASTATING TO THE BOTH
PARTIES REALLY AND SO AGAIN
THANK YOU SOMEONE MEMBER FOR FOR
BRINGING FOR THIS REALLY
IMPORTANT ALL.
THANK YOU THAT'S WITH US PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR STONE AND
THAT WAS THE COMMITTEE MY NAME'S
JASON CONLON REPRESENTATION
SPECIALS WITH CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION CFA AS A CO SPONSOR
OF THIS BILL.
WHEN I DISCUSS ISSUES WITH OUR
MEMBERS I CAN TELL YOU THAT MOST
OF THEM ASSUME THAT COP
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN THEM AND
ME ARE CONFIDENTIAL?
AND THAT INFORMATION WILL NOT BE
DISCLOSED TO THE EMPLOYER OR
OTHER THIRD PARTIES --
IN REPRESENTED THROUGH THIS
UNION COULD FAR MY UNION WERE UP
TO ME WITH OUR MEMBERS ON A
NUMBER OF SENSITIVE ISSUES
INCLUDING WORKPLACE DISCIPLINE
GRIEVANCES SEXUAL ASSAULT
HARASSMENT CIVIL RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS.
AND EVERYTHING UNDER THE SUN.
IS IMPORTANT FOR OUR WORK IN
RESOLVING WORKPLACE PROBLEM STEP
UNFILTERED CONVERSATION SO THAT
WE KNOW EVERYTHING INVOLVED IN A
SITUATION AND ON OCCASION TO
SOMETIMES GIVE BLUNT ADVICE TO
OUR MEMBERS.
I HAVE THREE EXAMPLES TO SHARE
WITH YOU THAT ILLUSTRATE THIS
NEED FOR PRIVILEGED
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN A UNION
REPRESENTATIVE IN OUR MEMBERS.
THE FIRST SCENARIO --
RECENTLY AT TWO SEPARATE
ARBITRATIONS WE LEARNED THAT THE
LONG BEACH STATE --
CAMPUS AND SACRAMENTO STATE YOUR
THE MEMBERS TO FIND THEIR
CORRESPONDENCE WITH UNION
REPRESENTATIVES AND OTHER PEOPLE.
THE CSU LAWYER COMMENTED THAT
THERE IS NO PRIVILEGE BETWEEN A
MEMBER IN THERE SEE IF A LEADERS
AND ADVOCATES.
EVEN WHEN THAT TOPIC IS TO
ADVISE ABOUT ENFORCING THE
CONTRACT EMPLOYMENT RIGHTS.
BUT BY DENYING THE PRIVILEGE TO
SEE IF YOU SEE AS YOU WAS ABLE
TO TAKE EMAIL CORRESPONDENCE
COMPLETELY OUT OF CONTEXT AND
PRESENT THOSE ADDED AN
ARBITRATION.
THE SECOND SCENARIO A CFA FIELD
STAFF MEMBER AT SAN JOSE WAS
SERVED WITH A SUBPOENA FOR ALL
OF FOR EMAILS WILL LIVE AGAIN
WHO IS SUING THE CSU FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS --
THIS LITIGANT HAD ENGAGED IN
NUMEROUS HUNDREDS OF PAGES OF
EMAILS WITH THE FAA ABOUT HER
EMPLOYMENT RIGHTS AS A FACULTY
MEMBER.
IN THIS YES YOU GOT ALL OF THEM
BECAUSE THE FIELD STAFF MEMBER
COULD NOT AVOID COMPLIANCE WITH
THE SUBPOENA THEY WEREN'T AN
ATTORNEY.
AND IN THE THIRD SCENARIO --
THERE WAS A RECENT INCIDENT IN
WHICH A FACULTY RIGHTS ADVOCATE
WAS ASKED.
THAT'S A GOOD STEWARD --
WAS AFTER THAT A SUBPOENA TO
PROVIDE COPIES OF EMAILS THAT
SHE HAD WITH THE FACULTY LED TO
GET IT CHANNEL ISLANDS.
AT THE CSU SIMPLY WANT ALL THE
ADVICE WE GIVE THE MEMBER OVER
HER EMPLOYMENT RIGHTS AND FOR
THIS ONE WE ADVISE THE FACT OF
THE RIGHTS CHAIR TO WAIT UNTIL
THERE'S A SUBPOENA.
IF UNIONS COULD AFFORD AN ARMY
OF IT OF LAWYERS THIS WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY BE AN ISSUE BUT THE
FACT OF THE MATTER IS THAT
REPRESENTATION WORK IS PERFORMED
BY FACULTY VOLUNTEERS A TRAINED
STAFF.
MOST MOST OF WHOM ARE NOT
ATTORNEYS --
OF MY COLLEAGUES TO DO THE SAME
WORK I DO OUR ATTORNEYS BUT I'M
NOT.
THIS MEANS THAT COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN THOSE.
TWO THOSE TWO COLLEAGUES AND
MEMBERS IS PROBABLY CATION
BETWEEN MEMBERS AND ME MAY NOT
BE PRIVILEGED.
THIS DESPITE THE FACT THAT WE DO
THE EXACT SAME WORK.
UNIONS ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
WORKING WITH THEIR MEMBERS TO
SOLVE PROBLEMS IN THE WORKPLACE
OFTENTIMES ON VERY SENSITIVE
ISSUES WE CAN SOLVE THOSE
PROBLEMS MORE EFFECTIVELY IF WE
CAN OF HONESTY COMPLETE
COMMUNICATIONS WITH OUR MEMBERS
WITHOUT WORRYING THAT OUR
PLAYERS GOING TO SUBPOENA THOSE
COMMUNICATIONS.
WE WILL THAT IS APPROPRIATE --
RIGHT UNION REPRESENTATIVES
PRIVILEGED COMMUNICATION WITH
OUR MEMBERS WE ORGY TO SUPPORT A
BEFORE EIGHTEEN THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I WOULD LIKE.
TO NO ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT IF YOU
COULD COME FORWARD TO THE
MICROPHONE AND GIVE YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION PLEASE.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ANOTHER CO
SPONSOR THE BILL AN ARCH RIVAL.
MR MEMBERS PACMAN WITH THEIR AND
READING ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTIST ORANGE
COUNTY EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS IN
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT ON SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHRISTY VELMA HERE ON
BEHALF TO CLIENTS THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS AND
VERY STRONG SUPPORT.
AND THE WRITERS GUILD OF AMERICA
WEST IN STRONG SUPPORT.
WE SHALL CAST OF THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
TELL JACKSON OF THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
CENTER BURGER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
TELL ME IF YOU COULD CLEAR THE
TABLE FOR THE OPPOSITION THANK
YOU
.
GOOD MORNING MORNING.
IS IS ON YEAH CAM STONE OF STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE CIVIL
JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA --
THAT CIVIL JUSTICE ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE ASSEMBLY BILL FOR
EIGHTEEN OUR MEMBERS BELIEVE
THAT READ RELEVANT EVIDENCE
SHOULD BE ADMISSIBLE.
IN TRIAL AND AVAILABLE TO THE
JURY OR THE FACT FINDER IN
ARBITRATION AND THAT THE WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO BE
CIRCUMSPECT IT WHEN GRANTING.
NEW OUR CREATING NEW PRIVILEGES
JUDGES DO HAVE DISCRETION TO
EXCLUDE SPECIFIC EVIDENCE FOR
EXAMPLE OF ITS MORE PREJUDICIAL
THAN PROBATIVE --
OUR MEMBERS AGREE WITH GOVERNOR
BROWN WHO VETOED A SIMILAR --
THAT MEASURE BEFORE MEMBER
RELATIONSHIP --
IS IS NOT ANALOGOUS TO THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN SPOUSES
BETWEEN A LAWYER AND A CLIENT.
BETWEEN A DOCTOR AND A PATIENT
BETWEEN A THERAPIST --
AND THEIR PATIENT OR BETWEEN A
CLERGYMAN PENITENT ALSO THIS
PRIVILEGE IS IS DIFFERENT THAN
THOSE OTHER PRIVILEGES IN THAT
IT RUNS BOTH WAYS.
BOTH THE WITH THE WORKER ARE AND
THE REPRESENTATIVE --
MAY HOLD THE PRIVILEGE AND THAT
COULD LEAD TO AN UNUSUAL
CONFLICT IF FOR EXAMPLE THERE
WAS A SITUATION WHERE THE
INDIVIDUAL WORKER MAY HAVE A
DIFFERENT INTEREST THAN THE
UNION AS A WHOLE AND THE UNION
REPRESENTATIVE COULD ASSERT THAT
PRIVILEGE --
THERE FOR OUR ORGANIZATION
REMAINS CONCERNS AND MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THAT'S WITH US PLEASE.
MORNING MR CHAIR JAPANESE --
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES --
REPRESENT NEEDS OF MY COLLEAGUES
WHO COULDN'T BE HERE.
THIS MORNING FROM THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES AND THAT CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
AND THE ASSOCIATION OF JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITIES --
WANTED TO SHARE OUR CONCERNS
WITH THE BILL AS WELL M. ABOUT
THE THIS THAT PRIVILEGE WHICH IS
DIFFERENT IN KIND FROM OTHER
EVIDENTIARY PRIVILEGES NOT JUST
IN IN DEGREE --
AND ARE CONCERNED THAT --
THIS PRIVILEGE COULD PAIN IN THE
TRUTH OF A SITUATION.
A LOT OF THE OTHER PRIVILEGES
NOT THE SPOUSAL ONE OF COURSE
REQUIRE A CERTAIN DEGREE OF OF
TRAINING AND LICENSURE IT THAT
INCLUDE AMONG MANY OTHER THINGS
THE THE TRAINING FOR PEOPLE TO
KNOW WHEN THEY HAD THESE
PRIVILEGES APPLY.
AT WHEN THEY DON'T AND SO WITH
THAT WITH THOSE COMMENTS WE'D
LIKE TO RESPECTFULLY.
URGE YOUR OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
YOU JUST COME FOR TO GIVE YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION PLEASE.
FAIR ABOUT JUST WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS AND
OPPOSITION.
JEAN HEARST HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN A POSITION.
LARA PRESTON ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHTS IN NONE OF BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
THERE IS A MOTION IS THERE
SECONDS.
MR HOLDEN HAS THE SECOND THANK
YOU MISTER KALRA N..
I THINK THIS LEGISLATURE DOES
TAKE THIS VERY SERIOUSLY AND
SHOULD WITH RESPECT TO
ESTABLISHING.
NEW EVIDENTIARY PRIVILEGES BUT
IN THIS CASE I THINK THERE.
THAT IS FAIRLY CLEAR THAT IT
SHOULD BE ESTABLISHED AND WHEN
WE LOOK AT WHERE WE'VE ALLOW
THESE PRIVILEGES BEFORE.
THE THE NATURE OF COMMUNICATIONS
IS WHAT WE LOOK AT AND THE RISK
OF THE INDIVIDUALS IS IS WHAT WE
LOOK AT THE I THINK THE
OPPOSITION THAT WAS COLOR BRINGS
UP AN INTERESTING POINT IN THAT
THIS.
PRIVILEGES HELD SORT OF BY TWO
DIFFERENT POTENTIALLY
CONFLICTING AREAS AND I THINK
FROM MY STANDPOINT THE BILL IS
SATISFACTORY I'M RECOMMENDING
AND I AND I DO HOPE WE PASS IT
OUT TODAY.
I THINK THAT'S ONE CRITICISM YOU
MIGHT WANT TO TAKE A LOOK AT HIS
IN EACH OF THESE CASES IT IS THE
DISCLOSURE OF THE INFORMATION
WHO TYPICALLY HOLDS THAT
PRIVILEGE AND CONTROLS THAT
PRIVILEGE.
AND I THINK IF WITH THIS WERE
STRUCTURED.
MORE LIKE.
OTHER PRIVILEGES IN A SIMILAR
WAY THAT THAT MIGHT.
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE CONCERN
BUT I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
WORTH LOOKING AT AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD.
RIGHT OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
SEEING NONE MISTER KALRA YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF
THE FEAR COMMENTS AS WELL AS THE
COMMENTS ABOUT SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION.
THIS BILL --
THERE'S NO DOUBT THE PROTECTING
EMPLOYEE RIGHTS IS A CORE
FUNCTION OF LABOR ORGANIZATIONS
AND AND I I WANT.
TO REALLY THANK FOR THE
EXCELLENT JOB AND DOES AND
DISCUSSING THESE ISSUES IN THE
REPORT --
INCLUDING THE ISSUE REGARDING
THE TWO WAY --
OF PRIVILEGE TO AND AS STATED IN
THE REPORT.
THAT --
UNION AGENT DOES OWE A DUTY NOT
ONLY THE EMPLOYEE BUT ALL THE
EMPLOYEES REPRESENTED BY THE
UNION I THINK.
IN THESE TIMES IT'S PARTICULARLY.
IMPORTANT THAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT
AND SO THAT A A SOMETHING THAT
I'LL CONTINUETO WORK.
WITH THE FUTURE COMMITTEES ON AS
WELL AS AS AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD I HOPE --
THE THE OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS
THAT ISSUE FURTHER --
AND IF MORE SPECIFICITY IS
NECESSARY OR IF THERE'S MORE --
WORKING NEEDED IN ORDER TO
JUSTIFY --
THAT TO A PRIVILEGE CERTAINLY UP
BECAUSE YOU TO WORK ON THAT BUT
I DO APPRECIATE THE THE AYE
RECOMMENDATION FOR TODAY'S
HEARING THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHY WOULD YOU HAVE OCEAN A
SECOND THE MOTION IS TO PASS
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE GALLAGHER?
CHAO.
CHU.
CHU AYE GONZALEZ.
INSULTS AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE.
OVER MENSEN KNOWN EACH
PETRIE-NORRIS YES.
THE BILL IS ALSO ON CALL THESE
AND OTHER VOTE.
SO WE WILL PUT ON CALL FOR OTHER
MEMBERS [inaudible]
THIS GONZALEZ.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB.
TWO EIGHTEEN ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION IS
THERE A SECOND.
ADD A SECOND MISTER TO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
MEMBERS AND MISTER CHAIR.
THIS SAD BILL OF COURSE YOU US
ALL LAST YEAR AND MOST OF YOU
VOTED FOR IT AND IT TO GET
VETOED BY OUR GOVERNOR AND WE'RE
BRINGING IT BACK THIS YEAR AGAIN --
PER SECOND SHOT AB TWO EIGHTEEN
EXTEND THE CIVIL STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS FOR IT VICTIMS OF
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ASSAULT FROM
AGE.
TWENTY SIX TO EIGHT FORTY IN
CASES OF DOUBLE DELAYED
DISCOVERY FROM THREE YEARS AFTER
THE DISCOVERY.
TO FIVE AND THE BILL WOULD ALSO
INCREASE AMOUNT DAMAGES
RECOVERABLE IN INSTANCES WHERE
THERE WAS A COVER UP THAT LED TO
FURTHER ABUSE AND ALLOW FOR
SHORT THREE YEAR WINDOW FOR PAST
VICTIMS TO SLIP THROUGH THE
CRACKS.
BASICALLY THE LONGER WE WAIT ON
THE BUILD PATTERN UNFORTUNATELY
OF ABUSE BY A NUMBER OF ENTITIES
THAT --
DESPITE EXTENDING THE STATUE OF
LIMITATIONS FOR CRIMINAL
BEHAVIOR --
JUST HAVEN'T BEEN ADDRESSED IN
IMPACT INSTITUTIONS THEMSELVES
HAVE BEEN A COMPLACENT AND BEEN
PART OF COVER UPS --
AND IN AS A RESULT MORE KIDS
HAVE BEEN ABUSED IT'S TIME IT
STOPS AND I THINK THIS BILL WILL
HELP PUT AN END TO THIS
PROLONGED --
BATTLE WE'RE HAVING
UNFORTUNATELY IN SOCIETY WHERE
WHERE AT THE EXPENSE OF ALL OF
US CHILDREN ARE BEING ABUSED.
BYE BYE FOLKS THEY SHOULD BE
ABLE TO TRUST AND INSTITUTIONS
ARE HIDING IT SO --
WITHOUT A RESPECT LAST NIGHT
ABOUT.
THANK YOU PRESS WITH US PLEASE
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN STONE AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS JOE WELL CAST X..
I WAS BORN AND RAISED IN SANTA
ANA AND STILL LIVE IN ORANGE
COUNTY.
I'M AN ADVOCATE FOR OTHER ADULT
SURVIVORS OF CHILD SEXUAL
ASSAULT LIKE MYSELF.
I HAD BECOME ONE OF THE LEADING
NATIONAL SPOKES PEOPLE ON BEHALF
OF VICTIMS.
AS A TEENAGER I WAS SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED BY THE CHOIR DIRECTOR
AT MY HIGH SCHOOL.
HE DELIBERATELY TARGETED ME.
BECAUSE I WAS VULNERABLE.
HE KNEW I WAS POWERLESS.
I HAD SPENT TIME IN A
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITAL FOR A
SUICIDE ATTEMPT.
MY MOTHER WAS AN ALCOHOLIC MY
FATHER WAS IN DENIAL.
I YEARNED FOR MENTORSHIP AND A
STRONG ADULT FIGURE IN MY LIFE.
I DID NOT YEARN FOR AN ADULT TO
SEXUALLY ASSAULT ME.
DURING THE TWO YEARS HE TARGETED
ME I WAS THE SUBJECT OF REPEATED
SEXUAL ASSAULTS AND RAPES ON
SCHOOL PROPERTY AND ELSEWHERE.
BY THE TIME I GRADUATED HIGH
SCHOOL I WAS PREGNANT AND HAD A
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED DISEASE.
AND LIKE MOST VICTIMS I LIVED
WITH CRIPPLING SHAME AND SECRECY
FOR MORE THAN A DECADE.
I AM NOT A FAMOUS PERSON.
I AM NOT A MOVIE STAR NOR A
GYMNAST.
I'M NOT A C. E. O. NOR CELEBRITY.
BUT IT IS NO LESS ON ME WHEN A
HARVEY WEINSTEIN OR A ROY MOORE
OR LARRY NASSER CUT A SWATH OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT ACROSS OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
IT IS NO LESS ON ME TO STAND
HERE BEFORE YOU AND SAY THAT OUR
LAW MUST CHANGE.
WE HAVE SEEN A COMPLETE SHIFT IN
OUR CULTURE WHEN IT COMES TO HOW
WE VIEW CHILD SEXUAL ASSAULT.
IT IS TIME TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
CULTURAL SHIFT.
I HUMBLY URGE YOU. TO VOTE I
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT IS PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS MIKE FINNIGAN I'M AN ATTORNEY
WHO WAS ASKED TO BE HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE VICTIM POLICY
INSTITUTE.
THE ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU COULD GIVE US YOUR NAME
AND YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE.
CAROLINE DON CAP YOU MAKE YOU
KEPT CAN ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
CRIME VICTIMS UNITED OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M NANCY PEPPERING
ON BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER TRAITS
OF CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK.
GIVE ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT SIGNAL OPPOSITION
.
THIS CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOHN OR
WOULD ON BEHALF THE INDEPENDENT
INSURANCE AGENTS AND BROKERS OF
CALIFORNIA --
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THIS BILL
CHANGING THE SPATULA TAKE HIS
AGE FROM TWENTY SIX TO FORTY AND
ANYTHING TO DO WITH PERPETRATORS
THIS HOW THIS BILL APPLIES TO
PERPETRATORS.
NOW WE RESPECTFULLY HAVE TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL --
IN THE VIEW OF OUR MEMBERS WE
THINK THIS BILL IS SO RADICAL IN
LIGHT OF WITH CALIFORNIA'S
ALREADY DONE IN THE SPACE.
THAT IT WILL EFFECTIVELY
ELIMINATE THE ABILITY OF OUR
MEMBERS TO SERVE --
BUSINESSES AND ORGANIZATIONS IN
THEIR DISTRICT WHICH INCLUDE
AMONG OTHERS OVER FORTY THOUSAND
DAY CARE AND FAMILY DAY CARE
FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
OVER THREE THOUSAND PRIVATE
SCHOOLS ZONING NINE THOUSAND
SCHOOLS --
NUMEROUS CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS
AND CLINICS AN UNTOLD NUMBER OF
NON PROFITS IN VARIOUS --
JANITORIAL CONSTRUCTION AYE.
TECH FIRMS THAT GO ON DO A
SCHOOL CAMPUSES THAT MANY
DISTRICT REQUIRED TO HAVE THIS
COVERAGE --
INSURANCE IS ALL ABOUT BALLOTS
AND WE WERE SEEING THAT IN THE
FIRE KIND OF A SITUATION RIGHT
NOW -- AND
WE THINK THIS SKEWS THE BALANCE.
CALIFORNIA ALREADY PROVIDES
VICTIMS WITH A LIFETIME --
TO BRING THEIR CASES AGAINST AN
EMPLOYER OF A PERPETRATOR --
CERTAINLY WE HAVE AGE TWENTY SIX
RIGHT NOW BUT ABOVE AGE TWENTY
SIX FOR THE REST OF YOUR LIFE AS
LONG AS THERE'S REPRESSED MEMORY
OR THE CLAIM OF REPRESSED MEMORY
YOU HAVE IN.
THE ABILITY TO BRING A CLAIM
AGAINST THE EMPLOYER OF THE
PERPETRATOR.
A CALIFORNIA.
IN ADDITION --
THE CURRENT STAFF NINETY X.
STATUE WE HAVE RIGHT NOW --
THE IN ADDITION CALIFORNIA'S ONE
OF ONLY FIVE STATES IF EVER WE
OPEN THE STATURE LIMITATIONS --
NATIONWIDE WERE TWENTY YEARS
AHEAD OF THE STATE'S THAT YOU'RE
SEEING DEBATE THIS TOPIC NOW IN
NEW YORK AND PENNSYLVANIA NEW
JERSEY CONNECTICUT THOSE TYPES
OF THINGS.
SO WE'VE GOT WE'VE DONE THAT
ONCE AND TO DO IT AGAIN I THINK
SENDS.
THE WRONG SIGNAL TO THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY THAT
BASICALLY IS IN A SITUATION
WHERE THE THERE WILL NEVER GET
OFF A RISK --
IN ADDITION THIS BILL THEN ADDS
TROUBLE DAMAGES IN A SITUATION
NOT TO PREVENT FUTURE CONTACT.
BUT RETROACTIVELY SO ESSENTIALLY
YOU'RE PUTTING VICTIMS IT COME.
FORWARD IN THE SECOND REVIVAL IN
THREE TIMES BETTER POSITION THE
VICTIMS A CELL JUST TEN YEARS
AGO.
I MEAN YOU YOU CAN'T CHANGE THE
FACTS AND CIRCUMSTANCES OF WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE FIFTIES SIXTIES
SEVENTIES EIGHTIES WERE THERE IN
FACT WAS COVER UPS YOU CAN'T
CHANGE THAT AND SO.
IT'S JUST AN INVITATION TO
TROUBLE DAMAGES --
WILL LASTLY THE BILL CHANGES THE
THRESHOLD FOR THE MOST LATE
LAWSUIT SOMEONE'S AFTER TWENTY
SIX OR IF THIS BILLS AMENDED TO
FORTY AFTER FORTY OR YOU'RE
TRYING TO SUE THE EMPLOYER.
WHERE NOW UNDER CURRENT LAW THE
EMPLOYER HAS TO HAVE SOME NOTICE
SOME KNOWLEDGE THAT TO THEIR
EMPLOYEE IF THERE IS IS?
PROBLEMATIC AND THEN DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING TO CHANGE THIS
BASICALLY SAYS IT'S A WAR SO
WITHOUT ANY NOTICE ALL THE
EMPLOYERS ARE HELD TO THE
HIGHEST STANDARD OF CARE OF
DOING SOMETHING IS ESSENTIALLY
STRICT LIABILITY FOR CASES ARE
ALMOST.
IMPOSSIBLE TO DEFEND SO --
POINT AND WILL DRIVE THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY AWAY FROM
THIS KIND OF COVERAGE IN THAT
WILL ACTUALLY RESULT IN
SITUATIONS.
THAT -- ARE
MORE RISKY FOR CHILDREN IN THAT
INSURERS IN ORDER TO GET THIS
KIND OF COVERAGE DO THE JOB OF
OF GUIDING OF TRAINING OF
TELLING --
BUSINESSES ORGANIZATIONS WITH A
NEED TO DO TO GET THIS COVERAGE
WHAT KIND OF POLICIES THEY HAVE
TO IMPLEMENT.
AND SO WE THINK IT ACTUALLY
MAKES A SAFER WORLD SO FOR THOSE
REASONS --
THAT'S OUR POSITION AND
APPRECIATE THAT BYE BYE.
THANK YOU SEX WITH US WITH GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS SERRA BOTCHES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS.
AND OUR EDUCATION COLLEAGUES
INCLUDING ACCESS CSPA THE
CALIFORNIA JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY ANOTHER'S WITHOUT
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION.
WE THINK ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ
FOR ALWAYS BEING A CHAMPION FOR
VICTIMS AND WE SINCERELY WANT TO
WORK TOGETHER ON THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE.
AS WE ARE SUPPORTED WITH THE
NEED TO PUT WELL THIS THE
ATTENDED IT REQUIRES AMENDMENTS
TO ENSURE SCHOOLS CAN IMPLEMENT
IN ORDER TO PREVENT THESE
HORRIBLE ACTS FROM EVER TAKING
PLACE AGAIN.
WE PROPOSED TO COMPLY WITH
EXTENDED STATURE OF LIMITATION
TO AGE FORTY THIS CHANGE IS
ESTIMATED -
TO COST AT A MINIMUM AND IMPOSE
A FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FROM DAMAGES AWARDS AND
SETTLEMENTS THE COST CA RANGE AS
HIGH AS HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
THIS ESTIMATE IS BASED ON OUR
ESTIMATE OF THE NUMBER OF NEW
CLAIMS TO BE MADE POSSIBLE BY
RELAXING THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS SO THAT A PLANE
TOUGH AS OLD AS FORTY YEARS OF
AGE.
CAN FILE A SEXUAL ASSAULT CLAIM
WE HAVE ALL NOT YET DERIVED AN
ESTIMATE AND FOR THE NEW CLAIMS
TO BE GENERATED BY THE BILL'S
OTHER PROVISIONS. TO RELAX THE
STATUE OF LIMITATIONS OR THE
BILL'S PROVISIONS CALLING FOR
THE STRICT LIABILITY TO REPLACE
NEGLECT NEGLIGENCE AS THE
STANDARD TO DETERMINE LIABILITY
BUT THESE PROVISIONS WERE
CLEARLY AT A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT.
TO THE NEW CLAIMS SIMILARLY THE
BILL'S PROVISION CALLS FOR
TROUBLE DAMAGES THAT ARE NOT YET
INCLUDED IN THE ESTIMATES
PROVIDED HERE.
BUT THERE WILL ALSO ADDED
SIGNIFICANT COST TO THE NEW
CLAIMS BEING MADE AS PART OF THE
SPELL.
WE HAVE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS THE SPECIFIC CONCERNS
WERE ASKING FOR THE REMOVAL OF
TREBLE DAMAGES PROPOSED IN THE
SPELL COUPLED WITH THE OTHER
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL THIS
COMPONENT WILL RESULT IN
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND COST TO
SCHOOLS. TO SETTLE CLAIMS THAT
ARE DECADES OLD AND OCCURRED
UNDER.
SCHOOL BOARDS AND ADMINISTRATORS
ARE LONG GONE WE LOOK.
WITH LITTLE TO NO EVIDENCE
AVAILABLE SCHOOL DISTRICTS WILL
BE FORCED TO SETTLE LAWSUITS
RESULTING AND DIVERSION OF
CRITICAL RESOURCES AND SERVICES
FOR TWO DAYS STUDENTS.
WELL WE CAN MAKE CHANGES TO
SUSTAIN AN INCREASE STATUE OF
LIMITATIONS THAT REQUIRES AN
ADDITIONAL FOURTEEN YEARS OF
COVERAGE FOR WHICH NO PREMIUM OR
SAVINGS HAVE BEEN SET ASIDE.
WE CANNOT SUSTAIN THE RISK AIMS
TO HAVE ALREADY BEEN SETTLED AS
THE BILL ALLOWS THEREFORE WE
REQUEST ELIMINATION OF THE THREE
YEAR REVIVAL WINDOW.
WE'RE ALSO ASKING FOR
CONSIDERATIONS OF REQUIREMENTS
FOR SCHOOLS TO IMPLEMENT ZERO
TOLERANCE PREVENTATIVE MEASURES
WHICH INCLUDE STRICTLY ENFORCED
PROCEDURES TO IDENTIFY AND ACT
UPON ANY INDICATION OF BEHAVIOR
THE CONSTITUTES ARE CUT LEAD TO
SEXUAL ABUSE.
PROCEDURES ALIKE IN DEPTH
TRAINING FOR TEACHERS STUDENTS
VOLUNTEERS AND OTHER SCHOOL
PERSONNEL.
THE EARLIEST POSSIBLE
INTERPRETATION WHEN SEXUAL ABUSE
HAS OCCURRED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE VICTIM IS GIVEN ALL
NECESSARY MEDICAL COVER AND
COUNSELING HAS ACCESS TO
COMPENSATION WITHIN THE SHORTEST
POSSIBLE TIME FRAME WITHOUT
HAVING TO GO THROUGH A TYPICAL
ADVERSE RURAL.
PROCEDURE THAT FORCES THEM TO
RELIEVE THE STRESS TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCES AND BOTTOM LINE
BENEFITS ATTORNEYS WE MUST FOCUS
ON PREVENTATIVE MEASURES AND
INCREASED TRAINING TO ENSURE
THAT THESE PROCEDURES ARE
UNDERSTOOD AND STRICTLY ADHERE.
TO WE NEED A COMPENSATION SYSTEM
THAT IS FAIR AND REASONABLE AND
DESIGNATED TO BRING SWEAT
COMPENSATION BEING A PROCESS
THAT MINIMIZES THE HARM TO OUR
VICTIMS.
WE NEED A STATEWIDE STRUCTURE
AND SUPPORT TO FORCE ALL OF
THESE MEASURES AND MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE NOT JUST WORDS ON
PAPER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
AND THOUGHTFUL DELIBERATION.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
IF YOU COULD COME FOR TO THE
MICROPHONE TO GIVE US YOUR NAME
AND YOUR AFFILIATION PLACE.
JERMAINE SIN CALIFORNIA CIVIL
LIBERTIES ADVOCACY IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING LEILANI I CANNOT ON
BEHALF OF THE SCHOOLS ACCESS
LIABILITY FUND IN OPPOSITION.
LARA PRESS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU OTHER THAN OPPOSITION.
I'D SAY NONE OF BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE.
IT'S IT'S INTERESTING THAT THE
OPPOSITION AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
IS IS FISCAL.
BUT ONE THINGS THAT.
WE LOSE IF WE ONLY LOOK AT
FISCAL IS THE DAMAGE AND IN THE
INDIVIDUALS THE VICTIMS WHO WHO
HAD BEEN HURT.
AND LOOKING FORWARD I WOULD HOPE
WE PUT IN PLACE ALL OF THE
PROCESSES AND PROCEDURES TO
PREVENT THIS FOR THE FUTURE.
BUT THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
LIVING.
TRYING TO LIVE WITH A GREAT DEAL
OF EMOTIONAL TRAUMA AND OTHER
ISSUES AND SINCE IT SEEMS TO BE
IN OUR CULTURE.
THE REMEDY FOR ALL KINDS OF HARM
IS MONEY.
WRITE A CHECK AND YOU'RE ALL
BETTER WHICH WE KNOW IS NOT
EXACTLY TRUE.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT ELSE TO DO AND
SO ARBITRARILY KIND OF CLOSING
THE DOOR. TO AND THEN STATURE
LIMITATIONS ARE ARBITRARY
STATEMENTS EIGHT CLOSING THE
DOOR. TO DO THAT THE ONE REMEDY
MONEY THAT SEEMS TO BE WHAT WE
CAN PROVIDE.
IS.
IS A REAL CHALLENGE SO I
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND THE FISCAL
IMPACT I THINK THAT'S BUT THAT'S
NOT THE QUESTION HERE.
SINCE THE APPROPRIATIONS OR
SOMEONE ELSE IS GOING TO NEED TO
DEAL WITH THAT.
FROM A POLICY STANDPOINT
ENSURING THAT VICTIMS.
HAVE REDRESS THAT'S REALLY WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT AND THAT'S
WHY I ENJOY THAT AYE
RECOMMENDATION.
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
RIGHT SIGNAL SKINS US TO MAKE
LOVE WELL --
IN SOME WAY I'M HEARTENED THAT I
FINALLY GOT AN ESTIMATED COST
FROM SCHOOLS IN ANOTHER WAY I'M
HORRIFIED.
BECAUSE IF WE THINK THAT BECAUSE
OF COVER UPS THAT THEY CLEARLY
KNOW ABOUT IN INCIDENCES OF
ABUSE THAT THEY CLEARLY KNOW
ABOUT.
THAT THERE'S HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN DAMAGE OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF DAMAGE OF
SUITS THAT ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
BE AND I HEARD THIS THEY'RE JUST
GOING TO HAVE TO BE SETTLED --
THAT THAT THE LACK OF EVIDENCE
GOES ON BOTH SIDES AFTER YEARS
SO IF THEY'RE SUGGESTING THESE
NUMBERS I I WOULD SUGGEST THAT
THEY'VE KNOWN ABOUT THIS FOR A
LONG TIME AND THEY'VE HELD THE
KEYS TO CHANGING BEHAVIOR.
I HAVE ANOTHER BILL TO TO DEAL
WITH THAT SITUATION BUT IT'S
MONEY IS IT IS NOT.
THE PANACEA OUR SITE SHOULDN'T
BE.
BUT UNTIL YOU MAKE PEOPLE HURT
THIS BEHAVIOR DOESN'T STOP AND
WE'VE SEEN THAT THIS WAS THIS
WAS TALKED ABOUT YEARS AGO IN
THIS BUILDING PEOPLE MIL.
YOU KNOW --
WE CAN WE CAN OPEN UP FOR A YEAR
AND WILL TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF
HURT AND THEN WE'LL MOVE FORWARD
AND YET THIS CONTINUES TO HAPPEN.
I WOULD I WOULD CLEAN THAT
PROTECTING OUR CHILDREN IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING WE CAN DO
AND PROTECTING OUR CHILDREN IN
PARTICULAR FROM CHILDHOOD SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
SOMETHING THAT WILL STAY WITH
THEM AND WE KNOW STAYS WITHIN
THEIR ENTIRE LIFE.
IN AN UPSET EVERY ASPECT OF
THEIR LIFE AND WE'RE SEEING MORE
AND MORE THAT IT TAKES YEARS AND
SOMETIMES DECADES TO DEAL WITH
THAT TYPE OF PAIN.
IF WE DON'T GET SERIOUS ABOUT
THE COVER UP OF ADULTS WHO ARE
HURTING CHILDREN SOMETHING THAT
HAS HAPPENED SYSTEMATICALLY IN
THIS COUNTRY FOR FAR TOO LONG IN
THE STATE.
THEN WE WILL NEVER STOP IT IN
THE FUTURE.
SOMEBODY WHO ABUSES HAS ON
AVERAGE OF FIFTY ONE VICTIMS
FIFTY ONE YEAH I WANT TO PUT IN
PLACE SOMETHING.
THAT'LL PREVENT.
VICTIM NUMBER [inaudible]
TWO NOT. TO SAVE A TWO THREE
FOUR FIVE SIX THIS IS A IT'S
ENOUGH IT'S ENOUGH IN EVERY DAY
WE SEE IN THE MEDIA.
THE THE THE EXTENT TO WHICH THIS
IS GROWING THE EXTENT TO WHICH
PEOPLE ARE WILLING TO SAY ARE
THAT'S NOT TOO SERIOUS I AM
HORRIFIED AT FROM THE THINGS I
READ.
ABOUT SUGGESTIONS THAT STATUTORY
RATE BETWEEN OF A TEACHER AND A
CHILD AREN'T THAT SERIOUS.
THAT SOMEHOW WE'RE DOING THAT
CHILD A FAVOR BY BY INTRODUCING
THEM TO FAX AND THAT WAS IN THE
NEWS TODAY.
THIS IS WHAT PEOPLE THINK AND
THAT'S WHY THIS IS NEVER BEEN
TAKEN SERIOUSLY AND THAT'S WHY
IT'S APPROPRIATE TO GIVE TREBLE
DAMAGES TO THE COVER UP AND
THAT'S WHY IT'S IMPORTANT.
THAT WE ACTUALLY MAKE
INSTITUTIONS FACE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THEIR PAST
BEHAVIOR SO THAT WE NEVER ARE IN
THIS POSITION AGAIN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AND I THANK YOU
MOTION WE DO HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND.
MOTION IS TO PASS KALRA PLEASE
STONE BY STONE I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO CHOW.
CHAO AYE CHU.
CHU AYE GONZALEZ I CONSULT I
HOLD KALRA [inaudible]
KILEY.
HEY WE KNOW MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO PETRIE-NORRIS REYES
[inaudible]
REYES AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH RIGHT WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF ITEMS ON CALLS
WE'RE GONNA GO THROUGH THE LIST.
POLICE WILL STARTS OF THEIR
ABSENT MEMBERS PLEASE SEE IF WE
CAN GET THEM BACK HERE WE START
WITH THE CONSENT AGENDA. THREE
WHICH IS ONLY AB THREE TWENTY
EIGHT SB THREE TWENTY SEVEN
HAVING BEEN PULLED FROM THAT
AGENDA SO ITEM SO THE CONSENT
AGENDA CALL THE UP TO MEMBERS
PLEASE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I KALRA [inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY I REYES.
REYES AYE.
THAT IS OUT ITEM NUMBER ONE IS
AB FIFTY FOUR MISTER TINGS BILL
IS ON CALL ME TO LIFT THE CALL
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I GALLAGHER I KALRA
[inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY AYE REYES.
REYES AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER TWO
IS AB ONE SEVENTY FIVE GIPSON
I'M GOING TO LIFT THE CALL.
GONZALEZ.
I GONZALEZ I KALRA.
KILEY.
KILEY NO RACE.
REYES AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER.
THREE IS OUT ITEM NUMBER FIVE IS
ON CALL ME TO LIFT THE CALL AB.
FOR EIGHTEEN KALRA CALL THE AT
THE MEMBERS PLEASE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO CHAO.
CHAO I REYES.
REYES AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER SIX
AB FOR TWENTY FOUR GABRIEL I'M
GONNA LIFT THE CALL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I KALRA [inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY I'D RADIUS.
REYES I THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB THREE TWENTY
SEVEN MAIN CHINA LIFT THE CALL.
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO GONZALEZ.
AND SALAS AYE AYE KALRA
[inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY AYE RADIUS.
REYES AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
RIGHT I'M GONNA HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR A LITTLE BIT I THINK
MISTER KALRA STILL NEEDS TO VOTE
ON A FEW.
OUR WHICH ONE ON ITEM NUMBER.
THREE NOT THAT ANY. TWO NINETEEN
YEAH.
SO AB -- TWO
EIGHTEEN GONZALEZ.
GALLAGHER --
NOTA NOT THE GALLAGHER NOTED NOT
VOTING.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
COOL [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
WE DID CONSENT.
THIS RECALL RIGHT.
LET'S ROLL THROUGH THIS THE
CONSENT AGENDA [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
ITEM ONE ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
FIFTY FOUR TING KALRA
[inaudible]
KALRA HIGH.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB ONE SEVENTY
FIVE GIPSON KALRA COLOR AYE.
THREE ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWO
EIGHTEEN GONZALEZ KALRA
[inaudible]
KALRA AYE [inaudible]
AND SIX ITEM NUMBER SIX AB FOR
TWENTY FOUR GABRIEL KALRA
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB THREE
TWENTY SEVEN MAIENSCHEIN KALRA.
KALRA.
LOVELY THAT COMPLETES OUR
BUSINESS FOR TODAY THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH WE ARE ADJOURNED